juniors vous ne l'attendait pas mais il
revient bien et préfère toujours ça fait
tellement rire ce truc là je rigole de
mes propres blagues nulles quoi ça va ça
ne va plus ça ne va plus dans le live
hier soir a été long pour ceux qui ont
suivi j'ai tout donné hier il n'y a plus
rien et n'a plus à rien dans chaque
ruelle d'or de rester au pouvoir
ça fait tellement fort marais speech et
je suis enfin vous n'attendiez pas mais
il est quand même là désolé mec ça me
fait vraiment marrer ces trucs là me
fait réellement marais je veux ici c'est
tellement une bonne bande annonce pour
ce tournoi peu importe je suis de bonne
humeur c'est déjà ça je rigole tous à la
mad max qui a personne sur le live
c'était quand même dommage c'est quand
même dommage j'ai quand même la
notification comme quoi c'est parti
c'est marrant attendait ce qu est ce que
les partis sont partis web on va se
mettre non oui ouais ça et ça vient de
partir attendez je vais bien tout va
ouvrir d'ici un mois mais c'était drôle
où ça n'amuse que moi en fait
enfin qui éludent vie pour venir si ça
une once de drôlerie ou pas si c'est une
once de rallier donc voir le match qui
skie qui débute je laisse les gens
arrivés petit à petit ya un pion isolé
ah non
donc oui ce qui est un point
d'interrogation quand je disais un vrai
foot et de st jean n'est pas en rapport
avec la dont a parlé dans le dvd sur le
pizzo les de cette position intéressant
pas clair tendu nangis l'on pourrait
dire le speech et juniors où on ne
l'attendait pas mais il est quand même
là c'est vrai ce que tu en penses
ludwig je sais pas s'il a pu entendre
lorsqu'il ya la pub et en plus avec
common stream sur youtube et et twitch
avec chaises comme c'est difficile
d'interagir avec le le chat c'est
dommage enfin oui mais non et jamais en
fait jamais en fait ce truc pensée genre
de pions de pendant avec le pion c3 donc
du coup avec un trou en c4 mais des
pions qui ce qui sent très bien et avec
un rock ces quatre pouces et trois des
cinq têtes qui arrivent et salue la
pièce salut à toi
on va voir comment comment il vous est
théorique 1 mais juste que tu connais
pas déjà il le connaît déjà plus on est
beaucoup mieux on et 1550 là qu'est ce
que c'est que ça qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est quoi ce bug
ou encore 1550 avec deux personnes et
mis dans chat fait voire s'améliorent il
y avait un bug de y avait plus de
personnes qu'il n'y en avait je pense et
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être l'inversé
les compteurs en sur les compteurs sont
en sueur et salua xul assez homepage
d'accord mais hier je pense qu'il y
avait un bug
hier je pense qu'il y avait un bug en ce
qui concerne il y avait au début en tout
cas il ya peut-être eu un bug de d'envoi
de notification ou quoi ouais c'est la
page d'accueil
bon bah du coup c'est le speech est
junior un tour avec personne n'attendait
mais qui a lieu salle et fanfan placer
ma blague avec du monde ce sera le père
saad nathan mais qui se joue quand même
bon du coup ces deux bons jeunes joueurs
et riga ici vont le connais pas vraiment
en fait il a 20 ans il a indien bon il
est là quoi il est fort mais mais il
sera jamais vraiment top mondial ça
c'est sûr et j'ai friction gh je pense
qu'il finira dans le top 20 mondial top
20 top 10 mais pas forcément plus et là
l'idée dame b 1
c'est du coup sûr petit rock on fait
tout proche cet échec c'est d'interdire
le rock en fait mais c'est pas forcément
terrible terrible et b prend à il a pris
un pion mais il va laisser c4 c5
ça se discute avec jean luc delarue
rappeler de cette émission ou pas vous
êtes trop jeune
vous êtes peut-être trop jeune pour
certains en tout cas dans le chat pour
vous rappeler de ça parce que même moi
j'étais petit quand ça passe à la télé
trop jeune pour axe ou 50 la quasi ça
rajeunit pas mais moi j'étais petit nez
s'est passé pendant longtemps non ça à
la télé ça se discute
j'en discutais juteux là je pense qu'à
faire ses 4 quand même parce que c'est
l'idée d'avoir dévié le pion baissé de
se procurer la casse et 5
ivey dame b5 d'accord il veut il veut
vraiment récupéré deux pions en vitesse
ouais d'un b 5e c'est bien aussi un
alors là est ce qu'on fait fou prend f3
on donne un père de fous ont détruit la
structure de pion à blanchet ce qu'on
fait petit rock j'en sais rien les gars
il a détruit la structure evian f 4 mais
ça va prendre prendre phu cat retour des
il va protéger le cavalier fait rock
après j'aime bien les noirs perso j'suis
pas vous préférez qui
vous préférez les blancs les noirs moi
je vois bien le scénario avec un carnet
qui va commencer à venir s'installer
yella en f4 d'air sur fou prend un f4 ya
peut-être dame prend à d'un france et
royaume 3e 2e et les tours centre
protège mais non c'est sûr que c'est
mieux pour les noirs le temps que tu
récupères le pion le gars warocqué il va
bouger son cavale ton roi au centre va
être dégueulasse ça se passe pas très
bien pour erika ici et dans le match moi
je mets avions gros favoris il a
impressionné dans le premier match
il est vraiment plus fort c'est mon sort
pas de maxime
j'ai apprécié votre cas qui voit les
blancs m après après après il ya des
arguments pour les blancs aussi un
peut-être le roi qui va partir en a eu
deux enfants juifs ou et 4 mais mon tour
des huit têtes tout reprend et essayer
de faire un dame j'ai ça amènera
peut-être d'amsterdam prend assez chaud
il fait dame ces six là je peux vous
dire que leur dire comment de rock avec
idées sur dante cette dame f3 mais ça tu
vas pas trop vouloir rentrer dedans
en tant qu'être humain trop compliqué
quand il fait froid e set c'est le coup
le plus logique
en réalité il protège son cavalier
failli garde la protection du kava liste
des clous le cavalier tient la case
d'échec il va vouloir faire tour ses
huit ont pensé 3
peut-être
4 parce que sur dame prend tu pourras
faire ffe ça c'est des trucs que vous
faites les gars ou vous faites pas ce
genre de truc genre pourrait changer
vous remettre les lions peuvent bien
comme il faut
vous faites jamais ça tu as dame e cat
là vous pensez à ce genre de trucs
george v m en échange pour me remettre
les lions comme il faut ou trop
compliqué tu es le sky arts des échecs
un peu ouais enfin les gamins je suis
qu'à 20 gros je suis quel point je suis
moi quoi je suis je suis personne de
rien tout dépend de la situation
ça se trouve au quai du ku'damm ses
satires met pas en place ils attaquent
ces trois tours à 3x place y défend et
il prépare peut-être un rock tour 1 et
attaquer ça je sais pas ce qu'il veut
faire de son roi peut-être il veut faire
3d de toi tu va soumettre leur ont
demandé de les faire tous réussi leur ok
quand même quoi qu'il en soit au tour 1
je suis également les changes pour
remettre la structure mais sans en
évaluer de la pause juste comme ça oui
c'est déjà pas mal ainsi déjà tu le fais
fabre et non plus j'évalue rien du tout
je te rassure un look classe
je me remets la structure je m'en remets
à la structure après dieu seul sait si
c'est bon ou mauvais un truc intéressant
sur wife fuite qui pourrait paraître
sympa et peut-être des fous prend 1,7 ce
qui aura pas g600 fermement à cause de
dame prend et a quand même bien envie
d'aller le chopper soyons c'est après tu
as un yvan colonna qui peut partir j'ai
besoin que les blancs jouent un peu plus
disparate il ya des buts moins précis
que les noirs away il joue de manière
plus dynamique
eisenberg gaming toile on pourrait faire
aussi voilà faut prendre un set c'est
intéressant après ses couilles en fait
peut-être sur fou prend achètent ils
voulaient dames 7 gagne un tempo sur la
tour protège le cavalier puis g63 g7
mais qui peut le faire éventuellement
maintenant hélas il fait dame g3 alors
il rajoute de la pression évidemment sur
les sur les pions colonna mais il veut
aussi dame prend h prend ou est franc
pour se remettre la structure bien une
nouvelle fois
bon évidemment les noirs et changent pas
ils échangent lui et ses quatre mâles
cavalia terrien b4 le fou peut pas se
barrer en f1 puisque à qui réalisent ces
deux problèmes
donc il doit se barrer en sur cette
diagonale mais y aurait eu tout reprend
ses cadres dont qu'il fait c'est 5 et la
tour des huit ouais c'est il ya tout qui
tombe là c'est à temps pour prendre et
encore tout reprend à 5
elle fait un tour b 1 et tours prend des
4es et maintenant tour je sais pas tour
d un cavalier c'est à non non non la
tour est protégée et carré des cinq donc
y avoir un coup de foudre entoure à
quatre ils empêchent cavaliers f4 on
prend ces 5
ouais ses deux pions plus face à un pion
de plus attaque sur le roi jean retour
c'est un cavalier f4 ça va arriver il ya
il ya un gros mur russie 7 5 contre le
fu b1 et tour c'est en plus ça attaque
le fou et ça cloud donc il doit calculer
tour c'est un tour à 8,3 et vii
torah c'est 3g six fours bouge tour j'ai
un échec crois-je trois cavaliers f4
watch 4 est ce qu'après roi assis sur un
g5 matt force et c'est la question qui
la fef 4 mais là dessus a pas juste on
reprend b1 saab en droit à ces pièces de
plus et en plus ya un rebond du cavaly
vers h5 pour protéger cette ça fait 1 0
pour jefferies jefferies tranquille un
montpetit jefferies qui à mon avis va
base gagner ce match tranquillement il
est fort le joueur américain craquage ou
web après après les noirs étaient mieux
toulon il a il n'a pas vraiment craqué
en mode
il a donné une position gagnante high
tech w ludwig pp la fin pp l'ofs dans
les faux châtaignes j'ai l'âge et le
mode vibreur
alors ça lui as tu pas de rex 69 du cou
qui est là pour la première fois ici
donc h6 on protège et cinq tours fc un
protège la cage et 5
ouais c'est un peu un peu un peu
n'importe quoi j'étais en train de poser
le téléphone on se donne aussi la case
h7 pour le fou en repli ouais tu vas au
moins la sueur cavaliers h4 on a des
fois cette truc typique de systèmes de
londres donc on a ces fameuses position
avec double fiant kétou qui sont l' arme
secrète pour me battre avec les blancs
je le dis souvent quand je commente les
parties mais je trouve ses positions
mais tellement dur à jouer pour les
noirs je n'arrive jamais à sentir perso
à quel moment je peux faire c'est 500
trop affaiblir sur la diagonale si je
dois jouer 5 si je dois rien faire je
trouve que c'est très pénible à jouer
avec les noirs après je comprends que
y'a rien de spécial pour les blancs mais
je trouve ces positions très dures parce
qu'avec les blancs talent et le cadre
des 5e 4 5 lés à 3 b 4 mettre la
pression qu'ils avaient trois cavaliers
c5 ya plein de plans et avec les noirs
en gros tu as et cinq ou aux 5 ou tout
est changé mais la pression des blancs
et est pénible à long terme en fait c
vraiment un pénible à jouer avec les
noirs je trouve bon après à partir d'un
certain niveau les joueurs me met en
difficulté parce que voilà je vous conte
des jambes en ce niveau là comme que
comme comme eric baïsse il acquis et
2960 sur une chaise comme et qui sont
des joueurs qui réussissent à maintenir
la pression pendant très longtemps on va
peut-être faire un cavalier qui a aidé
trois peut-être des 4es et 5es qui a
valu aux 5
on est mis 150 on est juste en première
page à guillaume aurait en réalité on
n'est pas très nombreux et salua b49 est
ce qui nous met un petit un petit et
modes de gaël choquet qui a fait
cavalier ou 5
alors la question sera est ce que
l'échangé favorable mais parfois on peut
même prendre 2d avec l'idée de jouer pas
avec cavaliers des six plus tard ou avec
4,4 g 4 f 5 est complètement annihilé le
fou ça c'est une idée qui peut être très
pénible dans cette structure du coût qui
avait lieu 5 et très bien joué je
l'avais pas vu comme ça de bages
j'avais vu cavaliers prend pour la façon
cavaliers prendrait pas possible mais
même s'il était possible ça me
paraissait être qu'un échange et
échanger des pièces c'est plutôt en
faveur des noirs alors tiens pourquoi
est ce que les échanges de pièces sont
favorables pour les noirs dans le chat
ça j'aimerais bien qu'on me réponde
allez hop hop hop hop hop hop le tchad
je veux des réponses pourquoi est ce que
les noirs seraient plutôt content
d'échanger quelques pièces on va voir on
va voir à quel point ça suit comment ça
c'est qu'on va mieux les couvents des
spectateurs d'une partie que quand on
joue pas ce que tu revois que la surface
m yogourt quand tu es spectateurs t'as
pas besoin de rentrer dans la profondeur
c'est plus facile moins d'espacé non un
petit problème d'espacé normalement ils
doivent échanger combien de pièces
mineurs quand on joue avec trois rangées
contre contre 4 on doit échanger combien
de pièces mineurs pourraient dans la
normalité pour plus avoir de problèmes
d' espace normalement général c'est quoi
la règle quand mm yougov ces deux pièces
mineurs normalement c'est une généralité
1 il arrive que ce soit une il arrive
que ce soit 3 il arrive que ce soit 0
mais normalement ces deux normalement
ces deux mais le truc c'est que là ils
laissent pas les changer comme on l'a vu
il donnerait des prend 1,5
bah ouais mais là il va être mal que
j'ai pris ça me saoule à chaque fois les
gens qui vivent ça avec les noirs ils se
retrouvent mal en tout cas il est moins
bien il va y avoir un f4 j'écarte f5
après c'est pas un énorme avantage mais
celle avantage qui augmente quand le
carême valley arriveront des six et qui
s'échangera il ya le four b2 qui va
s'ouvrir
dion que se fait masser et il m'a sert
d'ailleurs en se faisant masser
bah ouais on fait les jeux de mots qu'on
peut aussi un voilà après n'est pas
remonté de raymond devos qui veut
tu es b 5 il essaye de se libérer un
coup à laquelle un coup de merde
non mais c'est peut-être la bonne
décision mais ça veut dire que ça allait
pas trop avant parce que ab dame prend
b5 qui a quand même déjà des des petits
problèmes mais après ça ça tient sur un
fil a annoncé que jean piat les blancs
et je suis complètement à l'envers les
gars désolé parce qu'en fait ils sont de
l'autre côté sur un écran désolé exporté
au ta raison broad façon on s'en fiche
c'est pareil c'est l'indien du cookie en
sueur comme comme je les vois comme joie
les caméras de dans l'autre sens en fait
j'ai l'impression que la caméra duo
c'est que jong mais oui tu as raison
bon alors après ça change rien à la
partie à ce qui se passe sur l'échiquier
du coup c'est eric a ici qui est sous
pression est là ça ça va être au bout la
sarre est relou bananier il est dans le
dur donc à prendre prendre prendre dames
c'est d'eux qu'il a essayé de contrer
par tour b8 la bonne chose c'est qu'ils
évitent ce plan qui fait mal si je
prends un f4 f5 g4 c'est terrible
salut antonymes ouais non là c'est assez
compliqué donc ça risque de faire 2 0
mais le scénario
donc il va échanger et tours à huit
carélie ses sept tours c8 qui est bessin
qui va réussir à empêcher fois à troyes
de justesse repris de justesse
il reprend la casse de justesse que qaïs
et 7 on n'a pas le temps de foix iii en
attaque la tour tour s'est vite on
attaque le cavalier cavaliers bessin
qu'on empêche x 3 pour le clouage hummer
triais sa part être le seul coup mais
amiens peut-être cavaliers des caraïbes
et six tours prend b3 cavaliers des
ceintures à tourbes et un échec fois f1
fou prend 1,4 car il y prend f8 et ça va
aller
donc il prend ses 6 et g5
alors qu'est ce qu'il est en train de
faire avec les noirs il se libère il se
libère
bon il a un pion de moins mais il ya
plus que des pions sur une aile
et ça a l'air d'aller plus ou moins
alors peut-être qu'un truc comme h3 fou
c'est un f4 wen ont l'impression qu'on
va se prendre un tour b un bon pénible à
un moment donné il fallait quatre direct
way ont eu beaucoup mieux joué que ce
que je propose est alors prise prise
comment est-ce qu'on peut l'apprécier
avec les blancs juste sa position est
bizarre parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
pièces qui sont accrochées les unes aux
autres
mais d'un autre côté elles sont protégés
par la tour alors là ya pas deux fois 3
et le cavalier qui tient sur tours s'est
vite il ya cavaliers à 7 à tour c'est
lui qui à sept tours f8 roi et fuit deux
fois trois cas ici 6 et là tu commence
quand même à presser donc tour ses huit
avec qui des jeux cloud et peut-être un
jour j'ai des prises x 3 ça peut être
une option mais surtout celui de tête il
jouera roi g7 du coup à et peut-être on
pourra faire f5 suroît g7 acquis des
surprises d'avoir aussi c'est de faire
briller le fou mon rêve de une autre
option très logique
il veut peut-être juste 3 3 et essayer
de stabiliser un peu quelque chose alors
qu'il continue à presser
alors est-ce que c'est des joueurs pros
mais pipeau smac tv fou g6 bonfoh
justice c'est pas un mauvais coup en
soit il replace son fouillis protège son
pion il peut libérer du roi h7 fou j'ai
sept peut-être il peut y avoir des
fourrages 5
on croit que trois cavaliers à 7 tours
ses sept quarts aile et b5 pour ses 8
ouais c'est perdre au tempo parce que tu
peux pas faire cavalier à 7 à cause de
tout reprendre fuite
et maintenant il se prend le f5 dont on
parlait et e6 c'est exactement ce dont
je vous ai parlé juste avant les gars
désolé de spolier la partie c'est
exactement l'idée que dont je parlais et
f6 cinq ici c'est assez marrant comme
structure ça est assez rare comme
structure j'ai peut-être j'arrive une
structure pareil dans ma vie incroyable
les pions comme ça de côté
aïe prend b2 très bien joué prise b2
pour pour enlever cette attaque car
maintenant peut-être est-ce qui prend f6
ou est ce qui prend b2 il s prend 2,5
que s'y prend b2 puis on prend 1,5 le
problème c'est que les deux pions sont
forts mais d'un autre côté ils
conservent un pion à eux six pro f 6.6
prend b2 prend 1,6
il a plus de pions passer ça va être nul
alors à temps x 3 c'était un peu bizarre
ah oui mais attend non pas bizarre du
tout le fou était attaqué par dont
j'avais pas tout suivi j'avais pas tout
vu bien évidemment alors il met le camp
des cats il ya deux pions eux qui est
menacée il est bien tenu il ya je dois
attaquer et tour c'est six fois cette
prise
accueil des 5e quatre terribles en la
tactique d'occasion et surtout 17 tours
c'est cathy tient tout ça fait deux
aires pour giang
qu'est-ce qu'il a bien calculé les amis
avec très peu de temps sur la pendule
il a trouvé il a trouvé les tactiques il
a très très bien joué la jeffry prend il
prend un 2-0 lead ça peut faire mal hein
faut faire attention côté côté indien
il faut faire très attention la côté
indien te voir les classements bull est
à peu près équivalent en comptant 1 + 1
mais là il va falloir être très très
méfiants parce que ça pourrait ça
pourrait vraiment tourner tourner en
faveur d'actions graphiquement ce match
c'est un joueur qui a l'habitude des
joutes du top mondial jefferies giang
il a joué des grandes chaînes sourds il
a déjà croisé le fer avec les meilleurs
mondiaux
eric baïsse il n'y a pas cette
expérience et ça peut faire une
différence surtout sur des matches longs
comme ça tu frictions qui est un joueur
un petit peu plus fort qui doit avoir 80
points de plus en feed qui a pas un très
gros lots sur internet mais peut-être
parce qu'il essaye pas vraiment d'en
avoir un et là on voit on voit qui fait
mal d'entrée d'ailleurs pour la petite
histoire un des deux title cluzet dans
lesquelles j'avais fini dans les prix
j'avais battu jeffreys diongue à l'avant
dernière partie avec une robe à l'avant
dernière ronde
voilà
are you know voir je ne suis pas comme
encore prononcer son prénom qui est qui
se met tout de suite en danger on a vu
beaucoup de matches comme ça
dernièrement la notamment le match de
lundi où un score s'est construit un
plus plus 4 + 5 qui a qui s'était
dessinée rapidement pour ike et qui
avait été mené jusqu'à son terme
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut pas laisser
un avantage comme ça se construire donc
là dans cette ouverture c'était un
gambit d'alain genre de système kolb lui
en parlait ce qui va prendre en d3
intermédiaire reprise des trois et
prendre des 5 ou est-ce qu'il va prendre
des 5
je pense y apprendre du fou plus tôt il
pourrait aussi d'essayer de prendre des
deux et prendre des cinq et on verrait
le fou vous allez voir à mon avis va
jouer - est-ce qui va se jouer donc j'ai
bien fait de pas bouger les pièces là
y'a pas tu ailles et peut-être des six
intermédiaire mais non je crois bien
mesdames g5 menace m'attend en g2 donc
là on voit bien le four b2 emmuré dans
le pion et le fou des cinq qui rayonne
jeu price c'est clair pour vous mais à
les noirs sont déjà mieux
je trouve que visuellement comme ça on
peut expliquer la position sans sans
rentrer dans plus de détails
ça se voit juste il ya un flou mais deux
qui tape qui tape dans du noir pas
attendu blanc là pour la peine mais qui
tape sur un mur noir / / / enfin sur un
mur un pion blanc mais met donc qui tape
dans une muraille de cassure cases
noires et le full acquis fin qui brille
qui brille a atteint parce qu'il est
bloqué par par les pions blancs mais du
coup les blancs sont obligés quelque
part d'utiliser leurs pions de plus à
l'est le roi pour bloquer le four et les
noirs vont pouvoir a essayé de pousser
après ça si un sûrement avec les blancs
mais c'est les noirs déjà qui presse
après ça doit pas être cata pour les
blancs mais bon tu mets aucune pression
est là il va falloir faire attention à
un côté côté riga ici parce que si père
celle là attention à lui
ça pourrait rapidement faire cher ça
pourrait très vite faire très cher ça
pourrait très vite faire très très cher
autour du temps à faire tourner cette
tour des huit
allez mon petit e jefferies c'est ce qui
fait fermer tous rangs des huit faut
faire gaffe un jour entre pape pas se
prendre un fou prend f3 qui dévierait la
dame pour perdre la tour en d2 s'est pas
encore d'actualité mais ça pourrait
exister
voilà on se retrouve dans une position
il pourrait y avoir un statut quo ils
ont clés noires pourraient décider aussi
de ne pas essayer de la gagner et de
faire nul pour pas se faire contrer
par fo bessette ouais ça va échanger ça
doit pas suffire pour jouer le gain avec
les noirs on va tout échanger photos
couleur opposée elle va être nulle la
finale pour des cinqs pour fait retour
des 8es dames 1 tour 17 et d'amd 8
madame c7
ça va changer savard est de changer ça
met une dame en d2 la partie et pas
forcément passionnante peut se passer
des choses encore un mais normalement
les noirs doivent pas pouvoir avancer le
pion plus loin que ces quatre en fait il
doit pas pouvoir rentrer sur les cases
noires les cases blanches sont
complètement blindé par les pions
enfin comme vous il ya juste du monde
parce que le truc et en première page un
faux pas pensé qu' il ya deux mille
personnes qui regardent ya presque
personne dans le tchat
il ya trois messages et demi dans le
chat les gars on n'est pas très nombreux
en vrai vous faites vraiment toujours
plus piéger par le même truc sur twitter
en fait s'ils voulaient savoir s'il ya
du monde qui regarde quelque chose ou
pas un bain bonne chance de savoir c'est
de regarder le chat en fait si le chat
est actif ou pas c'est pas forcément
toujours valable mais c'est une bonne
manière de sa lancia du monde voyons
celui qui fait des demies message ici
rilov plus de 2200 sa rive passant même
en force page web après il ya aussi le
talent du commentateur soyons soyons
sérieux mais souvent s'ils voulaient
vraiment genre hier qu on était 600 ou
700 à 1h du mat à minuit et demi fond
n'étaient encore six ans on était plus
nombreux sur le chat que la queue que la
avec 2800 personnes ça ils sont
subjugués par les commentaires
exactement ya moins on a été 900 même
hier mais c'est à 23 heures et quelques
après après à 00h30 1h du mat note
également corps et dans les six ans
c'était pas mal c'était pas mal du tout
non n'a pas réussi à faire de 1800 on a
fait 2 1793 hier avant de recommencer à
perdre et finir à 27,70 on s'est
complètement nuls en sept parties pour
ça que je peux arrêter d'en parler c'est
max 27 93 ont arrêté à 27 70 du coup
j'ai beaucoup joué ça fait 8 heures de
stream
je vous avoue que j'ai un petit à un
petit mal de tête là pensons-y des sadc
de faire 3 8/3 17,3 c6 b4 à beac à
troyes b 5 à 3 à 2
ce serait la meilleure chance pour
essayer de gagner de réussir à faire ça
mais normalement il va pas y arriver
d'ailleurs il va juste faire h4 là avec
les noirs âgés seraient sûrement une
faute ça permettrait h 5 h 4g 3g 2 qui
est fait c'est juste pas possible de
réfléchir à ce coup ça h4 tempo là en
fait peut-être pas une super technique
en finale côté indien
c'est ça c'est d'être trop plat tu mets
juste hongrois en c3 est à temps vous
ces 5 fu des six après voilà tu forces à
quatre peut-être pas forcément très
malin mais mon bep trois rois des trois
pouces et 6 x 5 x 4 3 c3 et c'est nul
placez nul 2 partout c'est je sais même
pas à quoi ils réfléchissent
l'acfc enfin je sais même pas quoi on
pense en fait ici tu avais la technique
en finale n'est pas parfaite 1 ça
m'étonne quand même et peut-être qu'ils
ont besoin de calculer j'en sais rien
mais le roi des 3 x 6 x 5 x 4 3 c3 3,17
jura paroisse bk tu aurais b2 pour y
faire pousser trois foulées de roi c'est
3-1 ce fait nul aussi il faut remettre
le front des cinq mais ça a fait un nul
peut même jouer le b2i 6 il veut jefri
qui propose nul c'est accepter nos flics
à rien aux chais pas il essaie peut-être
se mettre une pression j'en sais rien
j'en sais rien
jefferies qui réfléchit il a déjà mis de
la pression tout à l'heure il va essayer
d'en remettre plutôt un bon résultat
pour lui pour le moment il n'a jamais
été en danger
il a pris les points quand il a pu là il
a mis la pression avec les noirs et là
nouveau les blancs il veut arriver dans
la zone du +4 +51 cette fameuse zone
dont on parle
pendant tous ces speech est si on a le
temps d'en parler a vu à quel point
c'est long mais c'est cette zone où tu
commences à être un peu tranquille le
match n'est pas complètement gagné mais
tu peux même avoir une baisse de régime
qui te fait pas remonter tout de suite
quoi donc là normalement ils vont encore
un peu poussé pour pro rivas +4 +5
après ils pourraient être plus en
gestion dans ces parties il presserait
peut-être moins des positions comme la
position précédente
il gérait plus son match aruna raison en
pls ouais on sent qu'il est moins fort
en fait ça ça sent dans les parties que
jefferies est plus fort
j'ai vraiment a vraiment le ressenti
tours fc un sens le pouvoir être un coup
ici l'idée c'est que sur cd on voudrait
échanger la dame contre les deux tours
ce qui est plutôt en faveur des blancs
l'avantagé est clair net et précis pour
pour les blancs rouges et 2 qui brille
sur la diagonale qui est pénible
comme je disais pour moi c'est un enfer
à tous avec les noirs contre un joueur
comme young jeu serait désespéré je suis
déprimé d'avant cela d'avoir cette
position encore un match à sens unique
ouais possible on se dirige vers un
genre de scénario comme sarlat il peut y
avoir poussé 3 la dame ne peut aller
plus quant à 6 on pourrait changer et
doubler les pions alors après serait pas
un avantage décisif mais on augmente
l'avantagent petit à petit mon aventin
on a nos ventes l'avantagent petit à
petit côté blanc ont fait mal on fait
même très mal donc ça c'est une option
après on peut juste faire un statu quo
pourrait jouer n'importe quel coût même
et ça ça parait pas idiot ça pour être
vrai ça pourrait être un match à sens
unique on va voir c'est pas dit encore
un pur long comme je vous dis + 2 on est
encore dans une zone qui peut être une
zone de turbulence +4 on arrive dans la
zone sécuritaire ou là où l'avion a
dépassé dépasser les les nuages il monte
dans la stratosphère
je sais pas comment ça s'appelle le
l'altitude à laquelle les avions ont
leur vol de croisière mais on restera le
vol de croisière pour la compagnie
jefferies xiong
il en est pas loin le petit jefferies il
en est pas loin
on va voir si si si réalise cela ou pas
regardez juste un petit peu le chat
youtube aussi n'ai pas beaucoup de
messages après clic c'est comment
aujourd'hui de se traîner sur plusieurs
plateformes pas vraiment interac pour
répondre comme la plupart des grosses
trimer sont soit full full full twitch
ou full full youtube c'est dans les
échecs que ça a été lancée mais je
n'arrive pas trop à comprendre le truc
mais oui ça joue bien d'après toi ouais
ouais ça je voudrais avant pas mal hein
ça joue vraiment pas mal franchement guy
longueuil joue vraiment bien
est-ce que possibilité d'adoption je
pense pas on va tenter moi j'aurais
poussé 3 j'aurais poussé trois persos il
a fait cavalier ou 5 il a attaqué j'ai 4
e4 maintenant il attaque le foufou j'ai
ici s'il veut peut-être prendre g6 faire
pousser trois échanges et en a six il a
peut-être placé un stade intermédiaire
avant en fait
est ce qu'il ya vraiment le choix
est ce qu'il a vraiment le choix que de
faire autre chose que fout g6
j'entendrai
les charmer tout reprend des katja fou
prend donc ça c'est une existence ou g4
c'est bizarre alors maintenant fous ces
trois ils lui enchaîne tout en fait dame
prend à 6 bea
il va prendre j'ai ici c'est alger et à
prendre ces 5
donc vous prend
st oui là le temps de prendre angers 6,5
toute façon est peut-être fois à 5
protège des 2 et prépare peut-être b4 et
joue le clouage j'étais en train de
réfléchir à ça quand vous m'avez vu
black out quelques secondes
pour ces cinq alors sur cavaillé j'ai
ici s'il veut quoi hg fou beccaria tour
c'est un sur échec par non je pensais
que j'avais le temps de faire vos
propres recettes mais c'est sûr échec
d'accord ça peut tenir jefferies là qui
a réfléchi longtemps mais qui après je
peux vous dire ce que donne l'ordi mais
c'est hyper dur à voir il donne qu'à
valider ces quatre équidés quand tu
prends prend et prend il ya foule b4
attaque
tu dois faire tour ses 7es fois à 5
ça tient grâce à ce truc tactique mais à
ça j'aurais jamais pensé en fait qui a
aidé ces quatre j'aurais jamais pensé je
pense que tu fais kg 6 pions g6 écoute
cavaliers il a fait tour à 2 ouais alors
il veut tour ces deux et protège le
cavalier surtout reprend ses trois tons
france et roya plus cavalier en l'air
le danger c'est qu il est cloué pendant
un coup donc il doit faire tour à ses
2000 va être sous le clouage
la structure est pas sic attaque ça pour
les noirs parce que c'est un deux contre
deux ici si on réussit pas à faire un
fouet fin vous prend à 6 ça va en fait
elle va prendre g6 c'est quasi sûr et
fouet fin ils laissent là il s le fou en
vie mais il menace fougue et 4
maintenant parce qu'il y aura plus à
tour prend ces deux il ya le clouage
mais c'est ça à moi en fait j'aurais
même pas pour ça qu'il prend 17
je suis vraiment fait blancs dans ses
positions tomber ça qui est bien joué
puisque sur b4 et tout reprend ses
quatre fous b4 fou prend b4 à prendre b4
et surtout reprend b4 ils doivent avoir
un cavalier à 5 j'imagine échanger et
même s'il a un pion de moins le truc
c'est que c'est les pions à et qui
rentrent en premier sur la 7e je crois
que et riga ici s'en sort bien là je
pense que ça l'a elle et elle est
maintenant correct pour les noirs a
laissé bien pour le joueur indien
pour preuve les quatre qui a aidé 6 ok
mais tout reprend ces deux là plutôt
partisan à cinq je protège b3 et je
rebondis verser 6 fait tour à 2 j'aurais
fait cavaler à cinq quand même
mais il veut tourbe et quatre tours à 6
tours b 3 tours à 7
et ça va être nul 1 1
car alice et 5 qui prend 1,4 à y fêter
ses 5 et prend b3 1 et du coup lui peut
se retrouver mal aimé voir quoi tour ces
trois sur tours c'est oui tu as écris
des six tours france et trois tours à
huit matches mais peut-être sur tour ces
trois des cas et des 4 mai à ce qu'avait
lieu de du coup il a fait tomber un non
mais ça va pas du tout pour pour les
blancs et c'est bien eric a ici qui va
revenir au score à la tour c 8 ça doit
être fort tour c1 est fou détroit bon il
a fait ce qu'il a fait à h5 lui à tour
en 1 prise prisé prix f3 ouais ça ça
gagne ses deux pions de plus s'il va
mettre le pion h4 je pense alors est-ce
que la finale de fou peut se tenir
c'est celle qu'il faut tenter à aimer le
pion h et de la bonne couleur
il doit pas y avoir de scénario ça tiens
ça
normalement il va pouvoir créer deux
pions passé lié à normalement il ya
aucun problème à gagner ça il va faire
il va essayer d'organiser g5 et après il
va faire les deux pions passé lié avec
la f4 bon du coup là il va faire flouer
6 h 4 du coup j'ai 6 h 4 il aura les
deux pions passé lié sa gagne tout seul
ouais
du coup il a abandonné ça se gagne tout
seul un pion de moi c'est nul dans ces
finales dames et deux pions évidemment
ces deux fois plus davantage et ça a
gagné bon ça fait 2-1
eric a ici qui remonte jefferies qui a
une bonne position mais qui qui ces
plans tailler mais qui ces plans taillé
pour enseigner avec un pion parce qu'en
fait à la fin il va rester un pion passé
et le fou va sacrifier contrer ça fera
nul avec deux pions ça faisait peu de
doute que ces gagnants après à la
question c'était de savoir s'il pouvait
y avoir un petit problème technique
quelque part mais la finale était
vraiment très simple à jouer un peu
différemment de la première fois il
avait mis son fou en d2
match plus tôt plutôt serré du coup pour
le moment l'écart n'a pas n'a pas été
fait
salut wspa d'a5 [ __ ] signifie sa ville
puis une seconde à chaque coup
exactement fatzer c'est un peu long
encore l'a40 moi je trouve pas que la
cadence spécialement longue je trouve
que 1h30 de cette cadence avec d'autres
cadence à suivre c'est un peu trop long
devra enlever le plus à chaque coup bon
moi je suis pas spécialement qu'on se
plus un mois je dirais c'est la finale
ans un quart de finale télé fera oui
très éthéré fera houle moi je serais
pour mettre que une heure de cette
cadence au lieu de 1h30 genre là ce
serait la dernière partie de la cadence
ce serait bien ça ferait cinq parties
s'apprécie par cinq parties où elle
serait bien
donc fougue et cinq ans la menace et
cavaliers 5 1 mais on peut l'empêcher
par fou prend à f3 il a échangé d'abord
mais c'est ce qui fait et on rejoue
cette structure là c'était plutôt bien
passé pour jefferies dans la première
j'imagine fou des trois pires depuis
toujours j'ai un put our c1 alors c'est
moins pire que la dernière fois pour les
blancs parce que là au moins il
n'empêche le rock et les pièces noires
sont un peu moins organisés mais je
trouve ces positions l'a tellement plus
facile à jouer pour les noirs
est-ce que je dois encore des cours
d'échecs malheureusement j'ai plus le
temps un backflip te prend de nouveaux
élèves
je fais beaucoup trop de choses tu
ramènes déjà aujourd'hui on est mercredi
je suis déjà en manque de sommeil quoi
donc qui affaires carélie f4
ça très pénible le scav allait me semble
supérieur aux foules à une super case
proche du roi où il contrôle plein dit
les tentaculaires
tu dois peut-être hockey quand même sur
damas mais adam prend m haies dames
français 3 à se venger sur b 6
peut-être qu'il faut rauque et quand
même la tour peut dîner un pion et
revient à sa position en prennent
surtout reprend va prendre ici on va pas
la laisser éliminer le pion sans se
venger
je pensais à l'autre
j'ai pas vraiment compris ce que tu
voulais dire tahiti bob switch roi des
deux tu t'exposes adam f4 l'a fait
tomber trois mamans il peut lui refaire
la même que tout à l'heure et seief 5
ça bloque le fou et après farewell vii
et ramener les tours et le roi pourra se
cacher la tour blanche peut manger g7
elle n'est pas en phase 1 maintenant que
tu es 3d 2 du coup avec deux coups
simples ouais enfin tu vas pas vraiment
avoir le temps de le faire parce que tu
vois là par exemple déjà les noirs ils
créent des menaces c'est un poil long
surtout qu'un simple coup comme f5 qu'on
a envie de le conte et a envie de faire
défendre et le pion
je suis convaincu que cette position
elle peut pas être saine pour les blancs
les noirs sont peut-être pas gagnant 1
mais a près le roi des deux est bien
placé ici du coup comme ya plus d'un
mètre 4
qui est l'échangé roi 17 il veut mettre
la tour ans et 8 et la dame en f4
d'accord il fâche 3 alors h3c pour
éviter toutes empreintes de seins qui
peuvent arriver
et là il a joué tour ses huit donc c'est
les coupes je vous annonçais l'échangé
bizarre oui et non ce cavalier il
obstrue un peu le jeu aussi ce cas le
truc c'est qu'il venait à ces dames f4
mais il va peut-être faire g5 pour venir
en f4 avec saddam dams et 6 il veut
peut-être dam des cinq dames f5 dame g5
et venir aussi s'en prendre à ça
dalé f5 aussi mf5 fera f3 faut voir si
réussi à maintenir tout envie ou pas
pas évident de progresser avec les noirs
même si l'avantagé est clair il veut
rentrer dans la finale ouais c'est rld à
tout reprendre et 6 il va faire dame
france et 3 il va faire tourner 8,6 je
pense ici sur touré cheikh tour c'est
cette fois il est forcément mieux parce
que les blancs ont des noms des pions et
live tour un v6 j'imagine ah ouais alors
pour la gagner faut tenter tour des 3 je
pense et tout reprend des quatre ça doit
être nul avec un bon jeu mais il va
presser avec les noirs
est ce qu'on est et non et les lots dans
une police lisible en attend je peux
essayer de faire comme ça mais de façon
les non tu les as à droite tu les auras
par en dessous
je m en noir
si c'est plus lisible comme ça moi je
vois pas exactement pour vous commencer
françois pour les lots les gars faut
vraiment vous concentrez vous
concentriez moins sûr sur les lots 1
vous êtes souvent concentrés sur les
lots c'est un gros défaut que vous avez
tous parce qu'en fait quand vous
regardez le jeu la qualité quoi prem's
et le temps du blu ray alors salage ça
je peux rien y faire
as tu veux dire le temps des policiers à
des différentes
ouais alors il va perdre f3 salaire
durant là pour est ce que toi un tour à
deux échanges et non ouais j'ai si la
justice est à tout reproche 7
il prend et prend à 4,8 c'est bien joué
souvent quand il ya beaucoup de tours
sur l'échiquier fin quand il ya deux
tours chacun il y avait beaucoup trop
d'échecs l'attendait tour des 8,3 ici
tour ici droit ici tour ici roi ici et
h4 est ça c'est nul il n'y a qu'un pion
de plus et le roi est coupée roi c'est 5
à ok veut mettre là tout ranger 4 faut
juste pas se prendre ce plan là ouais et
la g5
alors ça c'est une grosse question 3e 6
tours 8 3 f 7 tours h43 jce non paroisse
st croix g73 paroisse gc à roye g7 y
avaient tour à tour g6 maintenant droit
à sept tours f4 il doit il doit ils ont
f 4 3 6 et roy prend h5
il y avait peut-être torah je suis tout
reprend h4 est roi pour un f4 qui
faisait nul il a raté ça s'est vu sur
son visage
et maintenant si les noirs amène le roux
angers 4 c'est fini 3 5 c'est fini c'est
gagner tour h3 ici coupe le roi tour g3
maintenant pris 0 h 4 ça c'est fini il
ya le pion derrière roy ici et roy h30 h
un g2 3g un g4 3f de roy h 2 il a dû
rater là nul avec avec les blancs il ya
dû avoir un entourage suite tourcoing h4
qui faisait nul
il gagnait le plus avec quatre nuls on
l'a vu sur son visage ouais ça c'est la
théorie dont on parle avec mazet hier
pris ce prix f3 s'est lancé jay
frictions qui jouent cette structure et
là je pense qu'une vieille partie il ya
des vieilles parties notamment je pense
de fisher dans cette variante avec une
finale qui est censé être égal
je crois que c'est dan 17 ici cavalli
prend des cinq dames prend des cinq
dames prend des 5
je crois de mémoire les devoirs des
vieilles parties de fisher mais
s'attarde val d'or va nous le dire dans
le tchat
alors la question en fait si
réfléchissez ce qui fait battre en c3
classic ou est ce qui fait dame ces cinq
échecs dames france et 3 pour se
maintenir la structure saddam sera moins
bien placé et il se perdra les
possibilités deux fois trois échecs d'un
autre côté il y d'un autre côté il se
maintient à structure en place quoi ces
soirées ce que tu préfères tu as
structure ou est-ce que tu préfère avoir
le tempo de plus par là encore grosse
question est-ce que tu prends tu détruis
un peu la structure mais ça semble quand
même assez égal puisque a pas de pions
passé où est ce que tu fais tour b1 et
tu joues l'activité toujours pareil ces
questions position long terme court
terme
il a fait deux fois le choix du court
terme il ya des deux fois le choix du
court terme
ça peut payer 1 puisque l'activité
parfois ça rapporte
il mena stade des trucs genre fou g5 f6
dame bessette essieux faire droit à des
il y aura à tour des uns par exemple
avec un clouage il menace vraiment fou
g5 si je pense enfin menaces suivant ce
que tu joues rouges et 5 peut être un
coup dame prend f3 alors là il ya plein
d'options iliad à mme bessette qui
échangent les dames et qui active la
tour sur la 7e il ya tour g1 qui rajoute
une pression en fait bêtement sur g7 et
qui prépare peut-être ton g3 ya fois
trois intermédiaires il ya dame ces cinq
équidés sur wave six dames g5 maths qui
est joli donc je vais le mettre à
l'écran dams et 500 en vie mais il doit
vouloir peut-être 3,17 ils contre
attaquent la dame et yappa tour qui
arrive sur des îles a fêté ses 5 ça
donne super envie mais sur roy 17 le
truc pénible c'est que tannis tour
bessette ni tour des 1
fish a revu oui 63 c'était je savais que
c'était fisher avec les bons je
rappelais plus de jours avec les noirs
tard zelda dont huit dames p5 le retour
ça a répété une fois tu penses tu vas
faire ton géant ici
ces jouets il n'a pas envie de se
presser avec fo à 3 parce que fait
maintenant il va faire il pourrait faire
x 3 parce que survive si adam g5 maths
mais de base ils voulaient pas se
presser avec un échec comme ça pour le
moment sont fous il peut aller là il
peut aller là il peut aller jusque là il
peut aller jusque là sur damas katia
fouet 3 il a le temps sa fille pour une
fois une activité qui rapporte sans être
bombardés de charge
c'est complètement il garde ses options
et comme dit l dreams et surtout fois à
troyes maintenant effort parce que
j'utilise suroît f6 maintenant il ya
dame g5 mat
donc il forcerait trois des huit ce
serait cool donc la fois trois
maintenant il peut refaire ou f6 parce
qu'il ya plus d'âme g5
une des grosses questions maintenant
c'est d'amener cette dame prend bessette
tout reprendre et 7
il ya paroisse f6 à cause de fou g5 il
va y avoir des problèmes
il va falloir faire dame b cette prise
prise 3,8 et après on verra peut-être il
ya des fous ou trois rois deux tours d 1
tour 17 genre d'idée mais il a fait dame
b4 roi 8 damas quatre d'accord son idée
c'est quand tu dois faire dame 17 et
doit faire faire dame prend roi prend
tourbe et cède 3,8 sa transpose mais
s'efforçant car ils jouent bien que jong
maintenant il va échanger autour
bessette 3,8
ça rentre dans cette position de manière
vraiment très fort c'est moi tu peux
t'en terreau à ses 6 mai tampon fc r
c'est clair avantage blanc pas gagnant
c'est juste avantage tours 7e qui sera
forte
mais peut-être c'est ce qui va choisir
puisque roy 8 il est quand même bien
bien attaché
simon soir françois joucla je pense est
fou et 3 l'idée est simple c'est
d'attaquer à 7
et si le pion bouge droit de tourbe et
un tour b si ce serait le plan est
peut-être enfin deux variantes on gagne
h en fait si les noirs doivent
intervenir avec les deux tours en gros
se dit qu'on va gagner ce soit a soit h
avec les blancs on aura un pion de plus
moi je jeu pour pour moi il est friction
gay vraiment extrêmement dominant dans
ce match pour le moment et la tour j'ai
cinq jeux parce que vous en pensez mais
je trouve que déjà ils mènent au score
ça ça c'est sûr il a deux points de plus
mais au-delà de ça je trouve que son
niveau de jeu est quand même bien
supérieur
le coup logique si c'est torah 5 il va
faire à 6 il va être attaché aux deux
pions mais pour le monde gagne pas il va
faire tour ses 8000 le roi des trois
têtes il va la tenir et riga ici mais il
est vraiment sous pression dans toutes
les parties et ce qui est vraiment fort
dans ce que fait lyon que c'est qu'il
met la pression dans toutes les parties
mais il prend pas de risque celle qu'il
a perdue ok il s'est un peu trompé ça
arrive mais mais il a vraiment pressé de
a à z
la sq il a raté je pense c'est roi des
trois tours c'est cette qui va protéger
latéralement de pions et qui doit faire
nul tout de suite
ça devrait faire nulle part il ya ici
sous pression mais qui résiste
du coup il prend h7 et on g7
pour ces deux rois un tour b 8 tours
prend assisté twh 3 devrait bien jouer
tout rage 3 il va prendre h
non il n'y a plus assez de matériel
c'est nul ça c'est nul
en tête tour f 4 1
banques et vont faire annuler faire tour
3 ici mais la tour f 8
exemple qui a décidé de faire un nul et
il a bien raison
jefferies
donc ça fait 4 2 et on va avoir droit à
un petit système de londres
ou à un grand système de londres 1
pourquoi doit-il être petit à l'aller
par antec fou prend b1 tout reprend b un
fourbe et quatre échecs
3e 2 j'ai fouillé 4 direct ça doit jouer
aussi par bon les amis comme je suis un
petit à petit manque de sommeil
hier j'ai vraiment tout donné la foi
dans cette session de folie
la fatigue se fait légèrement ressentir
prises des 5 c'est bien qu'il ait pas je
connaissais la rente avec fou prend bien
fou des quatre échecs mais pas à prendre
un bain ça j'ai l'impression que c'était
mieux pour les blancs quand même parce
que sur cavaliers prend il va avoir un
problème c'est fou prend des huit
enfants ben et 8 roubaix 5 échecs roi f8
rock
même si ce n'est pas si grave d'avoir
été des rockets j'ai l'impression que la
scam un peu mieux pour les blancs c'est
juste pour vous expliquer pourquoi
accusions guettait a été déçu
alors voir ce que ça donne avec
languissait qui s'est trompé il va
devoir jouer cette fille cette position
là il va y avoir foule prend 2,8 c'est
sûr
doit reprendre en b 8 fou bessin qui a
peut-être m leroy e set
est ce que c'est si grave peut-être pas
il va comprendre des deux fers dame b 6
tours des 8,3 et fuite
ça doit aller quand même pour les noirs
damas cinq à oui ok d'accord sur à mes
attentions prend dame prend qui on prend
à nouveau cavalier b4 le marlou il
empêche rock et il veut cavaliers
detroit aux cavaliers c'est de bien
jouer ça de la part de jefferies ce
petit damas 5la intermédiaire est assez
sympa
salut velociraptor bonjour à toi d'avoir
ce qui fait un avec les avec les blancs
peut-être juste un coup de fouet de 1 et
tu menaces rapion prend mais qu'as tu à
provoquer les changements des deux mais
c'est vrai que tu vas peut-être pas te
retrouver avec un vrai avantage on voit
des frictions qui dansent sautent qui
dansent ou y je sens qu'ils écoutent de
la musique cette année au score du
tennis aussi benoît paire qui a perdu
aïe aïe aïe c'est terrible c'est
terrible ce qui est un français qui
s'est qualifié aujourd'hui c'était père
le premier à jouer il ya herbert qui est
menée était bonzi qui va se faire sortir
aussi c'est l'hécatombe un côté côté
tricolore à roland garros il s'est pris
il s'est pris le piège quand je
regardais ça fout des deux cas et d2 et
s'éprend d44 fourchette
alors il a dû se dire j'ai fou prend 1,4
lecavalier cloué mais regardez
maintenant il ya b4 des clous lecavalier
et attaque et attaque le fou il a tenté
sur l'enquêté prend b4 apprend des
quatre dames prend b4 et jouer les pions
mais on sent que les blancs sont mieux
ouais guillon consentait un qui faisait
pas une grande partie
non là c'est papa une grande partie de
la part de jefferies pensions quand même
le match avait plus serré que prévu
on va dire que jefferies domine mais
c'est la deuxième fois qu'il ya une
vraie baisse de régime alors qu'erica
ici il est un peu moins fort mais il est
très régulier
dans blue air de pig pour l'extraction
de pétrole ça secoue pas facilement
parce qu en fait d'après ce que je sais
qu'en si tu coupes la production c'est
pas forcément le plus dur mais c'est
difficile de leur remettre en route
parce que le pétrole y colle après et du
coup ça te pourrit tout ton système
c'est pas si simple c'est très coûteux à
redémarrer car a lieu trois prises prise
d'accord donc l'idée en fait enfin n'y a
pas d'idée en vrai il ya juste une pièce
de moins
on prend pas le problème sur puis on
prend un f5 ce que vit peut-être qu'il
veut tour des huit ouais mais au pire ya
rock ça va être pas bien loin en fait
trucks que ça c'est une pièce de moins
quand même quoi
toute façon il faut le prendre ce
cavalier inquiets ces quatre menaces
saâd a créé la dame et surtout reprendre
y aurait 15 points à 5
et maintenant ils varda me 1 et alors il
a quoi il a trois pions il ya peut-être
un dame g3 pénible ici ça attaque la
tour et surtout reprend de dame prend et
d'amd 2 pour attaquer j'ai deux il ya
dame g3 le retour assez terrible d'alger
trois salaires très fort
alors maintenant il ya peut-être tout
reprend f5 à l'équidé dame prendre à me
prendre trois dames prend des deux
filles et à fébé 4 et c'est la même
chose
quoique maintenant il ya plus prises en
trois il a peut-être pas tué
il va faire j'ai ici silva tout
consolider et peut-être fait roi et fuit
3g 7 et il tient un peu s'il réussit à
faire un jour à 6 g 5 à 4 à maintenir
son truc environ 2 3 c'est pas gagné
gagné encore tour précédent et je crois
que ça finissait la partie il a raté il
aurait pu conclure et riga et riga ici
mais il n'a pas conclu et ça peut être
louée à gagner sam arrive tellement
souvent ça moi j'essaie tant la ire à
tourcoing f5 de nouveaux arrêts non là
c'est très mauvaise partie de jefferies
que jong un comme un pion en un os
le son adversaire qui le rate voilà les
deux joueurs sont fatigués là il ya un
vrai coup de mou il va pas le rater deux
fois c'est pas possible
oh il aura ton corps terrible terrible
il a raté il a raté trois quatre fois
avant que j'ai pas vu quelque chose mais
c'est gros gros raté un raté un clouage
comme ça sur quatre coups d'affilée
ça semble témoigner d'un problème de
concentration un problème physique plus
que plus que niveaux joués la dame h4
c'est bien joué et il veut faire du h6
et venir réseauter le roi mais n'y a pas
d'âme des huit ans il ya la tour qui
contrôle
il va faire g5 f5 g4 si peu et encore un
peu de juin pour jefferies il a joué g5
j'ai une dame h5 qu'il veut et on peut
chez f5 adam prend g5 à yves adam prend
1,6 faut défendre
voilà tour des huit dames h3 forcé à
néant tout réussi mais tours 10 ah il
peut pas faire tourner et 6 passes qui
avait tourné un roi g8 dames la dame
prend 1 h 6 dames cette tour est fuite
hier pas en d2 ok il couvre les chèques
au fc chooz en vrai c'est très chaud
parce que s'il est noir réussissent à
envoyer s'il est noir réussissent à
envoyer f ça ça va être le feu un mois
c'est le feu les mecs six secondes
chacun ça envoie des deux côtés le pion
aux lampions béquille par a maintenant
presque on échange les dames ou pas
voilà dame qui va revenir en haïti s'il
a failli se prendre une fourchette la
dame qui va partir en 5
il va faire ou deux dames e3 et tout
reprend b6 hausse est terrible oh c'est
terrible tourache 6
quelle horreur ah ouais elle fait mal
celle là irene a ici qui a raté
tellement de gains dans cette partie il
s'écroule là on le voit on le voit la
caméra ça là elle fait très très mal il
a raté des tourcoing f5 les gars quand
même à plusieurs reprises il a raté pour
paris sans qu'il en a raté au moins
quatre des tourcoing f5 et ouais là il
est il est très très mal
ouais salle elle fait mal dans le match
parce que il a un peu dominé en fait sur
le sur les six premières parties
on va dire le plus de i l'époque est
quasiment bien payé mais bon ça va
et là tout d'un coup il ya une baisse de
régime de jefferies peut revenir à un
point et il commet sa première gaffe et
enfin c'est première gaffe il ya passe à
moins 3 et comme je vous ai expliqué ça
c'est la finale fischer way assez connu
et comme je vous l'aï expliqué moins
trois dans ces matches là on est dans la
mauvaise zone
zone de turbulences pour pour et vega
ici il reste neuf minutes dans cette
portion ça devrait être la dernière
partie et s'il la perd il passe à -4 et
le match est quasi perdu déjà pour pour
le joueur indien
ouais le clouage de tout reproche et
cinq étaient visibles la pièce mais
c'est la fatigue est là c'est la
répétition des efforts qui fait qu'à un
moment donné
bah on n'y arrive plus et qu'on commence
a gaffé
c'est aussi simple que ça
c'est aussi simple que ça il a fini par
craquer 1
mais c'est vrai que c'était une belle
une belle une belle une belle finale b
en fin de partie
ces partis tous les côtés bon la
position est égal j'ai juste un oeil au
second set final l'idée 1 pour les
blancs ça et essayer de pousser ses
pions
un jour et fixation des cinq pour
l'avoir joué avec les blancs et les
noirs franchement c'est pas la position
la plus excitante du monde mais bon si
tu es à l'aise en finale et que et que
tu as décidé dans le match de faire mal
dans ce secteur de jeu
ça peut être une idée elle presse
légèrement côté blanc elle presse
légèrement faut vraiment car il ya ici
trouve une nul 1 1 à ses fins ou qui la
gagne mais faut pas qu'il la perde
là je pense mentalement ce serait dur de
perdre une position gagnante et une
finale nul coup sur coup ça hypothèque
ray quasiment ses chances de
qualification je pense la tour cette
pétition parce que surtout on s'essaye à
tour 6 l'autre
pour eux si ceux-ci se regarde on croit
ses cinq tours d un tour c'est un tour d
un faitout russe est ce que j'aurais
joué aussi pour ses sept tours 6
et tu veux tu veux tout re six tours h7
en fait
wes peut commencer à être dangereux très
tendues pour erika ici celle là peut
être chiante en fait à défendre
maintenant il va chercher le con tre jeu
quelle est la grosse question c'est tour
6-3 ses cinq tours à 7 tours f4
je pense qu'il pourra faire tour ses
sept tours c3 je pense ça qu'il a
calculé il va revenir avec sa tour je
pense au tour ses sept tours c3 qui l'a
vu
ça qui est logique en fait ce que tend
ses 7 ans et 3 tu protèges le pion et tu
vas pouvoir revenir peut-être attaqué
celui-là
je vous cache pas que la position est
très complexe il doit calculer peut-être
tour c-53 b5 tour ces trois des quatre
tours des trois roues à ces quatre rois
ces deux et ça semble aller
en tout cas moi ça me paraît vraiment
logique de faire ça mais bon ce que toi
je crois tu as tour elle est quand même
mal placée elle revient jamais en jeu
quoique tout aussi tourache trois tours
j'ai 3 mais j'aime bien gagner en tempo
sur le roi et revenir centrale quand
même c'est vraiment ce que j'aurai
choisi perso après je sais pas un mais
tout ce qui m'embête d'enlever cette
tour c'est que fait j'ai envie de faire
monter le roi un peu par là et c'est
tout rend aussi ça allait bien elle
attaque
elle forcera un coup noir comme g5 ccabp
est d'enlever la turquie mais qui met
une menace en fait
on va avoir tout reprend g6 et c'est
encore une autre option au tour par f3
tour g2 qui va faire comme ça et c'est
encore une autre option
et en retour j'ai deux ici bahia tour g3
aussi à tanger 3 c'est intéressant parce
que surtout reprend tu peux reprendre de
f
fait tout rejet de jeu pense vraiment
que le machin etc pour ces trois étaient
plus forts après je me trompe peut-être
mais ça a laissé moins les noires
s'activent et sas a gardé une tour
active en fait assez et noir qui ont
tous le jeu
alain fait roi des huns
ce que je peux faire tout rejet 3 ici
une idée sans surprise à leur tour d2 je
pense surtout ranger trois affaires f4
on pourra peut-être faire ton g4
donc j'ai free qui propose nul ça
accepté reste plus qu'une ce qui reste
encore une partie dans la cadence
il en reste encore une dion qui est
parti normalement il doit prendre
forfait là dessus jefferies pas le droit
de partir un pendant l'époque à une
partie en cours il reste du temps ça
avant de jouer son premier coup ans afin
qu'ils soient qu'ils réussissent à faire
ces quatre décès
bryant des changes c'est la dernière en
5 puissant il restait quelques secondes
dans le chrono il a fait nul un peu trop
tôt bon après cette partie ce sera la
pause
la première
la première pause après il y aura une
heure de 3 + 1 puis une demi heure 2 1 +
1 on a l'habitude de ces matches qui ne
s'arrête jamais
on a fait bouger cathy clos je m'
allumer la lumière fait bien sombre ici
je mal aimé la lumière d'arrivants d'une
minute
et je suis de retour ma position
apparaît sympa pour les blancs quand
même davantage de développement claire
que vance eut ce fort match et anti
toile on va pas en reparler déjà passé
par les formats qui t'amène qu'est ce
que j'ai dit en début de live j'ai dit
le speech et juniors
l'événement que personne n'attendait
mais qui se joue quand même je me suis
fait une bonne phrase d'accroché pour
pour le tournoi
jusqu'au bout de l'ennui je dirais wspa
la non mais une heure et demie de match
c'est sympa mais là c'est beaucoup trop
diluée mais on a déjà parlé mille fois
ça tue tout toute la hype qui pourraient
exister sur sur un événement comme celui
là le speech à ce qui est super long way
en fait tu compte les trois speech à ce
fichage féminin speech est junior et à
le speech as réal qui va avoir lieu
ça fait trois mois de compétition sur
les 12 mois quoi ou trois mois et demi
même c'était un quart de l'année qui
occupait de truc qui s'appelle d'une
compétition qui s'appelle speech est
assez spécial ça apprend on n'y peut
rien ce que ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'en termes d'audience la
compétition de marche absolument pas
dans aucun langage et que ça fait 4
enfin ça fait deux ans que ça marche
plus du tout et que pour le moment
aucune décision n'a été prise pour pour
le modifier
on verra on verra si c'est si ça va se
faire si le modifier un jour ou l'autre
mais pour le moment ça ne fonctionne pas
ça ne vous donne plus la première saison
avait bien marché la deuxième saison
aussi à partir de la troisième ça a
commencé à baisser là c'est la quatrième
année et c'est de pire en pire et les
3100 vigueur c'est pas c'est pas un bug
rillettes c'est juste la première page
de twitch mais je crois qu'il ya pas et
c'est beaucoup de gens qui passent
quelques secondes mais qui restent pas
c'est un peu dommage d'avoir la première
page feront sur sur cet event en vrai
tout ça et pour les gens qui passent qui
viennent c'est pas forcément
et inspecteurs
ça marche on anglès quand ils ont pas de
premières pages il faudrait dans l'es8
9000 spectateurs sur czech comme minimum
100 premières pages parle à qui je passe
comme ça ben écoute merci
c'est yahia un vrai problème la
provision guerre reprenne là pour xu
gang qui à 0 pièces développées qui va
se prendre fou g5 saluera face caroff
après ouais le point comme quand ils
n'ont pas de premières pages
ils sont souvent entre 4000 et 5000
viewer sur un even comme ça quand tu
vois que pour un mini trip invitationnal
100 premières pages on fait 1500 2000 en
français
en sachant qu'ils sont aussi en
frontpage sur check point comme donc
fait quand tu as nous sur nos cévennes
custom on a à peu près autant de monde
en français ça veut dire beaucoup quand
même surtout raté un il veut cavaliers
des quatre pour essayer tout tenir il ya
peut-être se prendre un damas 3f 4,5 par
la suite je sais pas exactement ce
qu'ils gagnent ce qui gagne pas mais en
tout cas marc messier pas de premières
pages on serait 4 100 ou 300 aston stone
twitter on serait jamais 3601 mais même
là on n'est jamais 3600 comme je disais
hier
hier quand j'oublie de ça à minuit on
était six ans il y avait beaucoup plus
de messages sur le chat mais genre
beaucoup plus
donc donc il n'ya jamais 3600 personnes
en semant sur le live c'est impossible
c'est impossible
c'est exactement la vente que je vous
donnais caf 4 5 qui arrive
guillon qui va bientôt abandonné et qui
va pouvoir être déçus de tourner à plus
de un je vous le dis tout de suite il va
pouvoir être très déçu de tourner à plus
2 il aurait pu faire beaucoup mieux
il aurait pu faire beaucoup mieux
laprise prise il ya même dame français 5
qui tombent ici
le roi qui émaillent les atouts qui est
mal
donc il a fait faux quatre vingts savait
que j'arrivais ici à cause de twitch
mais c'est super intéressant mais après
comme je disais c'est ça arrive que des
evènes plus intéressant après sur les
écoule aussi un mets mes ccva d'avoir
une belle première page sur sur un event
qui est pas forcément le plus
intéressant qu'on est dans l'année mais
un coup comme 5 1 pour ouvrir le roi ça
peut être très fort déjà eu trois mille
six cents personnes
une fois on a fait 5800 ou si miller
affirme 06 kame avec une première page
aussi mais je crois qu'on est et 3500 en
organique de base
du coup si si ça arrive qui est du monde
et
pour qui pour personne en fait là je
pense dames 3 c'est très fort il y aura
le fou qui sera cloué il ya ça qui
attaquent à vii ya ça qui attaquent à
vii faut trouver comment tuer la
position ici dames 3 ça donne envie
parce que sur f 6 6 a pris 9 6 prises
avec 6 prises apsys le fou est cloué et
donc d'en prendre 5 arrive des frictions
qui va payer cher sa mauvaise technique
en finale dans la partie précédente
ok il sait ici ce meriva se prendre tour
f 6 et peut-être un dame france et 5
pour clôturer le truc
le roi est vraiment mal placé et sa
interdirait le petit rock pour quoique
même petit rock est pas une menace
ouais là je sais même pas ce que menacer
blanc mais je vois pas de coût pour les
noirs y a juste pas de coût pour les
noirs et ça fait ouais c'est la fin de
la cadence et ça fait plus deux pour gi
young
on va faire comme on fait d'habitude je
vais vous repassez l'ap la dernière
partie en rapide on va se faire une
petite pause de cinq petites minutes
entre entre les games allez je vais
mettre la petite pause
si vous êtes nouveau n'hésitez pas ça
vous plaît à follow la chaîne en
cliquant sur sur le petit coeur mais moi
je vais me faire une petite pause avant
de vous retrouver pour une nouvelle aire
de jeu allez hop c'est parti
pas de suite les gars
bon les mecs il fait l'exploit de manger
pendant la pause
l'extraordinaire extraordinaire exploit
du français mais c'était bien cool
prochain sommes battle bitstream n'y a
rien de prévu
tim james enfin c'était prévu d'en faire
moins de toute façon mais donc pour le
moins y'a rien de prévu
je crois que tout le monde est un peu
sorti de cette mode death of battles est
difficile d'organiser maintenant il est
difficile en organiser dans d'organiser
le deuxième set
et de toute façon c'est un peu relou en
bref un par mois en vrai c'est bien deux
maximum le dernier c'était ya deux
semaines
alors il y avait de moins en moins
d'inscrits olivier whaou seaway
complètement il ya de moins en moins de
gens qui voulaient jouer c'est vrai que
c'est un peu ça marche mais c'est un peu
quand même du lot quality compte un mois
je disais que ça me faisait plus de ça
me fait plus qui fait de blitz est en
fait je trouve ça plus intéressant que
ça battle après il ya master class après
alors il ya fable qui va faire des
parties pédagogique sur sur la pire que
d'ailleurs faut que je mette faut que je
mette le truc en ligne tiens je vais le
faire tout de suite pendant la première
partie se joue merci de m'avoir fait
penser mais pour les ouvertures c'est
une suite de coups on sait pas quoi ça
rebondisse et cette question
alors on va jouer le m je vais mettre le
petit truc sur les réseaux tué m le
petit lien hop comme ça s'est fait comme
ça c'est fait merci mr fait penser tu
préfères habite sa quasi n'importe quel
autre programme
non je dirais par exemple les master
classes ou quoi c'est plus qualitatif
que blitz et où même les parties
pédagogique en vrai c'est peut-être plus
qualitatif pour pour les gens qui
veulent apprendre mais
mais en fait on va dire que dans le
contenu de divertissement blitz et c'est
le meilleur rapport fun et chose qu'on
peut apprendre en même temps et
challenge laisse battle en fait on
regarde juste des gens joué comme des
pieds quoi ou comme des bras suivant
pour quelle communauté il joue quoi
disons qu'ils ont ça comme ça ils ont
glissé beats et c'est un peu à la
croisée des chemins
et puis un peu de challenge et où c'est
marrant c'est ça les soldes battle une
ou deux fois par mois c'est marrant mais
pas toutes les semaines non plus après
ça devient un peu relou quoi
de mon point de vue et saluer leur tige
essais et salua captain obvious dit bon
bout d'un moment fait afin de ré que ce
soit organisé les 7 battle en
compétition en fait en vrai pour que ça
reprenne de l'intérêt est là à chaque
fois c'est des petits matches amicaux
séparés les uns des autres
faudrait que ce soit que ce soit un truc
projet qui est du lion entre les matchs
quoi cette bataille assez unique pour le
côté communauté ouais ouais non non
c'est sûr mais bon après une prison le
match que tu gagnes que tu le perds n'y
a pas de compétition il n'y a rien
derrière donc à au bout d'un moment
c'est un peu redondant quoi c'est bien
de temps en temps mais une fois par
semaine c'est trop
tu es la valeur du roi en terme de force
captain obvious en finale c'est quatre
points à leroy qu'elle en a marre de
sortir la cb dit maxime ouais ouais bon
après c'est juste une question que la
force de voir des ce battle il ya pu y a
plus le côté excitation aux côtés m'a
rendu desbuquois c'est toujours la même
chose en fait
c'est toujours la même chose c'est
blender battles est pas ce battage c'est
blender battle les amis les amis c'est
plus la seule bataille c'est la blondeur
battle
ils sont nuls
[Musique]
demont 10,4 en ique leroy vaudrait
quatre points en finale quand il monte
je suis d'accord sur vous je sais max
que tu trop laid je savais en plus que
tu trolley je savais que tu trolley des
problèmes récents que j'aime bien c'est
avec maso bah écoute c'est bien mais il
était là hier maso du coup rien de
permis le but aurait mal on va en perdre
on va perdre plein de joueurs là ouais
après hier hier on avait pas mal de
monde qu'avant yama zuki qui jouit le
title hier c'est la première fois qu'en
maso passe il ya moins de monde mais
c'est toujours comme ça de façon
maintenant j'ai compris quand on fait
des nouveaux programmes
ça marche super bien au début puis après
petit à petit ça et à l'érosion
le seul truc qui continue à bien marcher
c'est quand je fais des blitz et goûter
c'est comme ça ça empêchera pas de
contenu et les master classes et seb dès
qu'il va faire un gros rush en thaï tô
accusés y aura tout de suite du monde
mais il y aura tout de suite beaucoup de
monde mais les deux trucs qui marchent
bien systématiquement sur la chaîne
c'est quand je fais des bis et quand on
suit maxime évidemment qui joue des
tournois que ce soit en partie
l'engouement rapide c'est les deux
choses que vous aimez le plus suivre je
crois depuis des années c'est ça
il était dans le dur hier mais en vrai
dans les audiences et de trucs qui
marchent comme vous me demandez à chaque
fois ces deux choses là qui on va dire
sur le long terme
marchi systématiquement
mais organiser une compet entre 7 par
exemple une équipe qui a une équipe fine
équipe baqim équipe maxime ouais mais
c'est vachement dur organisé psycho
c'est vachement long a organisé sa pas
vraiment de value un loyer just that
thing you si ça marche pas mal mvl pour
pour de vrai en plus pour la peine il ya
parfois un peu moins de monde mais il ya
tellement d'engagement en fait que ça
compense donc du coup après
mon gosse web après plein de gens qui
mise de mettre mon gosse mais ça
n'intéresse pas spécialement en fait
c'est juste un public de fainéants et
son brame demande des efforts non je
pense pas que ce soit ça stone qu'auteur
je pense juste que les gens y viennent
pour le fun et pour les punchline en
général et les master classes ça marche
ça me ça a pas mal marché constaté
mathieu qu'il a fait la dernière fois
sur sur les ordis a pas mal marché
celle de vlad leur dit elle est
intéressante et tout ça mais juste tu
peux pas faire trop de trucs comme ça
ouais les gens y viennent pour le trash
talk un captain obvious c'est ça ils
viennent pour le fun et sa façon comme
comme je vous disais en fait le truc
c'est que la chaîne vitrine c'est
seulement la deuxième chaîne au monde
qui est rentré dans le top 100 des
chaînes regardées dans un langage en
fait c'est que la chaîne d'hikaru suite
à ces lives avec excuse et c'est qu'il
rentrait dans le top 100 et il ya la
chaîne bitstream suite au fait que les
gens regardent en fait ce qui n'a pas
vraiment eu de de dette de gros
influenceurs bon il ya un peu kevin du
rire jaune si un peu parlé de ma chaîne
ou quoi mais ça je sais ça jamais été un
gros push j'ai pas fais 40 stream avec
squeeze quoi donc en fait logiquement ça
veut juste dire que bon là il va gagner
très friands il a il a une qualité de
plus il va prendre en c1 il va prendre
en a deux et ça va faire mal
donc en fait ça veut dire qu'avec les
échecs normalement on doit pas pouvoir
rentrer dans le top 100 juste parce
qu'il ya pas assez de gens qui jouent
aux échecs ce que la france est pas
vraiment un pays des chèques a évoqué
ses 3 kg et prend des 5 et ça va être
terminé et donc en fait
c'est sûrement lié à ça le fait que ce
qu'ils font des audiences c'est qu'il ya
pas mal de gens je pense qu'ils viennent
juste pour le trash talk but étoilé cas
métaux mais ça fait 2 live the jazz duke
c'est incomparable avec et ça a pas
vraiment fait augmenter les audiences en
plus pour la peine et ses deux live
c'est pas c'est pas quarante mille live
de deux potes scheme aps etc
ces deux live à un moment donné et c'est
pas c'est pas ça qui est way est
fondamentalement sa paille a pas eu
spécialement plus de monde après mais
donc je disais ça pour quoi
oui je sais ça pour dire que que du coup
du coup ce qui fait que ça marche
beaucoup mieux que toutes les autres
chaînes
c'est ce côté là trash talk que les
autres font pas en fait parce que je
crois que c'est la seule chaîne enfin je
suis le seul à me permettra au temps
d'autant trash talk en joue en fait
c'est on a l'impression que ça rap
contenders parfois bon là c'est vraiment
complètement gagnant à ses qualités pion
de plus fait ça ça peut se rater
évidemment mais
donc du coup ça explique pourquoi les
master classes et machin ou quoi ça
marche moins et qu'on réussit à faire
bien marché les blitz et même les
battles parce qu'il ya du trash talk
c'est parce qu'en fait en vrai d'après
ce que je comprends de plus en plus
c'est pas vraiment les échecs qui font
marcher le truc c'est le trash talk en
fait face pas de trash talk c'est
comment dire c'est le mélange et chaque
truc un peu marrant spectaculaire avec
un peu de trash talk au milieu et est un
peu de vivacité orale ces espèces est un
peu c'est un peu trash ou bien peu
spectacle un peu voilà c'est un peu
humour c'est un petit mélange d'un peu
tout sans être vulgaire quoi ouais voilà
ambiance sympa référence sympa un peu
trash mais ça reste gentillet parce que
je me trash talk moi même aussi donc je
suis le premier à dire que tout le monde
est nul mais je suis le premier à dire
que moi même je n'ai pas joué que je
suis nulle et que faux faux et qu'il
faut que j'arrête les échecs quoi parce
que quand on joue aussi mal que moi
c'est compliqué arias tient un sujet
intéressant avis sur ou sso qui a agité
la chronique en traitant les arméniens
de tricheurs je pense que wesley so
devraient être bannies live duchess
comme en fait tout simplement pour ça
j'exagère peut-être un peu mais je pense
qu'ils devraient prendre un ban des
compétitions parce qu'il n'a aucune
preuve de ce qu'il avance c'est de la
diffamation pure et simple
donc qu'ils apportent des preuves en
fait parce que moi peut-être que je vais
retourner la vie des questions et je
veux dire que wesley so triche depuis
toute sa vie mais apparemment je vais
pas le faire parce que j'ai aucune
preuve et que c'est sûrement faut donc
là je sais pas ils balancent des trucs
comme ça où sont les preuves
tiens là il y avait quatre c'est une
double attaque oulala ça joue mal oh là
là là c'est catastrophique le niveau de
jeu
c
catastrophique place est catastrophique
et pièces donner à toutes les parties
et carla fait une vidéo de ramonville en
parle j'ai pas vu chez fâché parce qu'il
a dit il car ou là dessus sur sur le
sujet des arméniens mais à mon avis doit
défendre les arméniens j'imagine qu'ils
caroux défend les arméniens aussi parce
que que dire que dire d'autre en fait
tout le monde soupçonne gravement les
argiles indoor fait quelque chose et
c'est même probable j'en sais rien je
sais pas en fait c'est pas le sujet mais
le truc c'est que ya pas de preuve donc
c'est très facile d'accuser ben ouais ça
à ces standards les plaies par est assez
standard façon si tu accuses les eagles
qui doit accuser hikaru pour les magnus
tour aussi donc au bout d'un moment tu
va accuser tout le monde alors chers au
bout d'un moment on s'en sort plus si on
parle des eagles en prod châssis qu'on
va parler di caro magnus tour
donc en fait on s'en sort plus c'est
cédé 3 sur internet ya pas de preuve ya
rien c'est tout faut arrêter sinon à
chaque fois que quelqu'un à faire une
bonne performance on va dire il a triché
c'est pas possible tu peux tu peux pas
c'est pas possible en fait faut arrêter
donc au bout d'un moment c'est soit vous
participez pas vous jouez pas et vous
fermez votre bouche soit soit bouffe un
jeu juste ça m'agace en fait j'ai très
énervé de ça on a pas on n'a pas à
parler des yoles comme ça a laissé mon
équipe tranquille sinon je vous dis on
peut parler tout le monde sinon on peut
on peut on va pas s'arrêter on va parler
tout le monde tout cas
mais en plus il a trouvé deux trois
coups suspect au moment où les arméniens
les a joués il a baissé la tête dix fois
d'affilée oui mais car où il regarde le
plafond tout le temps donc j'ai en fait
ça c'est très facile là parce qu'il
arménien du coup alors là c'est grave et
puis concerne américain assez bien non
non il faut arrêter ça les gars faut
faut arrêter ça faut arrêter ça s'est il
y en un qui américains là ils regardent
ils baissent il regarde le plafond on
peut faire le mec arménien il regarde en
bas il n'a pas le droit fin géré n'en
faut arrêter il n'y a rien il ya zéro
preuve tu as regardé en bas tu as
regardé machin peut-être tête il regarde
et vous m'avez compris mais qu'en fait
tu regardes c'est peut-être on sait pas
faut arrêter faut arrêter tout ça tout
de suite
faut arrêter ça
suite les arméniens ont gagné après que
ces compétitions sur internet mais
aucune valeur et qu'elles ne doivent
peut-être plus être organisées ou être
organisée différemment qu'il doit y
avoir plus de vérification etc
c'est vrai aussi mais il n'y a pas de
drame à faire sur les arméniens c'est
anormal
ouais moi quand je calcule je regarde un
peu à gauche à droite en haut ou en bas
à regarder en bas pourquoi pas hier
quand j'ai quand j'essaie calcul et de
bien jouer j'ai fermé les yeux pendant
30 secondes
et en plus oui c'est vrai que pendant ce
temps en plus il ya la guerre en arménie
donc enfin cesser bon après c'est pas
l'un qui empêche d'un cri fin mais bon
c'est n'importe quoi
mais comment vérifier il n'ya pas fou
prend saisit ici juste menace m'attends
à 7
je vous annonce que le match est terminé
eric a ici qui avait gagné une pièce
geffré qui gagne quand même y'a plus 4
je voudrais annonce qu' il n'y aura pas
de suspense dans ce match
non mais voilà pour moi les accusations
de saut j'ai trouvé ça très petit
mauvais perdants car nous on at on a
perdu en pro che slick sur des
connexions de maxime on n'a rien dit du
tout je rappelle que avant le début de
la compétition j'avais annoncé que
l'arménie gagnerait tous les matchs sur
internet et j'ai eu raison et je les
accuse de rien du tout alors que j'ai
annoncé enfin géré moi j'ai annoncé
avant je n'attends pas wesley so qui
perd la finale pour annoncer que
l'arménie va gagner et j'ai dit
l'arménie gagne avant la compétition il
n'y avait aucune chance pour les autres
équipes gelé a annoncé ça s'est passé
mais je les accuse pas tricher pour
autant enfin sous ils sont très très
fort bravo donc il faut arrêter et c'est
là ça ils ont perdu un match ça chiale
quoi c'est bon non je suis je suis très
agacé par ce truc là
j'avais dit avant la compétition j'avais
dit la saison d'avant qu'ils iraient
jusqu'en demi finale j'avais annoncé à
saison d'avant qui battrait tout le
monde mais ils ont battu toulouse va
j'annonce chaque saison en fait ils vont
aller très loin un bon bah voilà sont
très forts c'est tout
mais met donc c'est tout après en
revanche il pourrait amener un débat
constructif sur comment faire pour
arrêter d'avoir des suspicions et ça ce
serait positif
les deux meilleurs scoreurs ont été
bannis ont pas pu jouer la finale
ouais je sais juste mais moi les title
tuesday quand il gagne à chaque fois
j'ai annoncé depuis longtemps au lit
fischer 2 c'est comme blue guy pendant
très longtemps j'ai très très fort sur
internet
mais bon c'est tout va et c'est juste
que personne ne vérifie pas assez de c
c'est simple c'est comme si au tour de
france en fait au lieu de vérifier les
vélos de voir si les mecs mettre des
moteurs à l'intérieur ou quoi on vérifie
r on vérifie rien et après on accuse
tout le monde
bah je sais pas peut-être le problème du
coup c'est l'étoile sur internet c'est
pas les joueurs ça il ya une expression
américaine d'ailleurs qui dit blame the
game dont blind blind de game dans blind
players accuse le je n'accuse pas les
joueurs
c'est juste que si tu mets aucune
sécurité de rien surtout les tournois
qui a et c'est toutes plateformes
confondues 1 c'est fille de tchatche.com
et et tout le monde confondues ne
vérifient jamais rien et jamais personne
il faut pas venir chialer après avoir
des suspicions le problème c'est pas les
joueurs c'est que y'a rien qui est mis
en oeuvre pour permettre d'empêcher qui
est de la triche donc partant de là en
fait il faut fermer sa bouche
soit on joue pas la compétition parce
que il n'ya rien qui est vérifiée soit
on la joue et on accepte les règles et
point barre c'est tout et point barre
donc voila mon opinion là dessus les
joueurs ont joué en connaissance de
cause
non ils ont perdu il y aurait personne
qui s'est fait choper si l'on fait l'ont
fait de manière intelligente et de
manière à ce qu'ils se fassent pas
attraper ils sont pas faire attraper ils
n'ont pas triché point barre après c'est
aussi un peu la faute du public qui est
là on sens et dès qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
gagne 1,3 sur internet c'est comme quand
maxime a mal joué sur internet vous
étiez tout cela en mode je vous ai vu un
an té des makes him eu du mal sur
internet est ce que tu penses pour les
candidats c'est grave vous chialez du
lourd sur les tchats je vous voyez là je
vous ai dit les trois sur internet c r
ça sert à rien c'est si tu sais pas ce
que tu as en face tu as peut-être
stockfisch constat petit tu sais pas ce
que tu as en face
donc ça n'a pas de valeur on verra
constat revient sur l'échiquier et
maxime a répondu de la meilleure des
manières en faisant fermer la bouche de
tout le monde en bundesliga en faisant
quatre sur cinq est en gagnant des
points elo enjoint des super party c'est
tout ces voix là il a répondu sur
l'échiquier mais mais parce que tout le
monde sait que c'est on a sur internet
tu sais pas ce que tu en face de toi
donc après maintenant temps que le
public y croit qu'ils te disent super
match extraordinaire on avait un match
de grande qualité machin nanani nanana
ça continuera comme ça et puis c'est
tout c'est tout c'est ce point barre en
fait le jour où le public se rendra
compte que comme il ya zéro sécurité on
sait pas ce qu'on est en train de
regarder 20 peut-être que les sites et
les organisateurs feront quelque chose
pour s'assurer qu'on regarde des vrais
partis mais tant que tant le public
réagit pas ou quoi eh ben ça restera
comme ça et puis tant mieux ouais super
party bravo les arméniens vous êtes très
fort mais très très fort plus plus fort
que les américains plus fort que caruana
du fort que tout le monde fasse c'est
génial bravo à eux et c'est tout mais
moi je dis pas w spada de faire sans le
online c'est parce que j'ai dit ce que
je veux faire moi c'est du online ou
chez des arbitres chez les gens qui me
permet de savoir ce qui se passe mais
mais voilà ce n'est presque pas la faute
du coach prend des mesures je prends des
murs les mesures sont pas prises au tac
s'est peut-être joué point barre
voilà voilà le truc mais donc sont
accusés les jours les gens comme ça sans
aucune preuve je trouve pas que ce soit
très très très charlie ya pas fou fou
province à tfo des cinq une tête dame
prend b4 à la fin voilà du online comme
l'ont fait les russes pour les
olympiades dans des salles surveiller
exactement fusil 94
la solution est simple aucun
organisateur ne l'apprend tant que cette
décision ne sera pas prise
et bien ce ça continuera comme ça on
peut rien y faire
en tout cas c'est vraiment parce mars
café sauvé c'est après sofia chess comme
à mon avis de prendre ses
responsabilités après ils font comme ils
veulent mais tu peux aussi prendre des
responsabilités ban le joueur de ta
plate forme parce que il fait de la
déformation sur d'autres joueurs ça
pousse ça pourrait aussi être être faire
pourquoi pas
après moi doblo d'oberhof m'a accusé de
tricher le mec travail carrément chez de
chasse comme quoi tout le monde tout le
monde s'emballe heck
mais bon j'ai quand même de tricher sur
un forum tout le monde s'emballe avec un
il est encore là et ça se pavanent
encore mais personne n'a rien fait alors
qu'il avait aucune preuve
je les bats tu rejoins une robe je peux
rien le mec est nul pas de ma faute un
petit peu rien
ben non bobby fischer on aimait toujours
des hypothèses on pense qu'un mec triche
on sait pas quand on dit oui peut-être
site riche on passe à autre chose mais
tu vas pas écrire sur des forums que les
mecs en mettant leurs blaze et tous ont
triché il n'en sais rien pour arrêter
ils sont très très forts ils sont très
très fort c'est tout ce que tu peux dire
mais tu vas pas tu vas pas demandé que
les mecs soient bannis du truc faut
arrêter faut arrêter moi les gars contre
qui je me plains ces gens qui ont des
comptes anonymes donc c'est ça qui me
saoule c'est que c'est des gens anonymes
et qui peuvent refaire des comptes et
que du coup c'est infernal mais c'est
pas des gens précis en fait c'est des
gens qui via leurs comptes anonymes et
qui peuvent en refaire tout le temps à
longueur d'année refaire des comptes des
comptes des contres faire bannir en
refaire en fait au bout d'un moment
c'est fatigant mais ça c'est un autre
problème
tu as encore un autre problème le
problème des comptes anonymes
ça c'est encore un autre problème par
annie faire un
enfin peu importe
ouais ibanez ebay mais qu'ils se fassent
façon ils prennent des vpn machin qui
peut rien par mon
non plus sur le match ou à se laisser
abuser
sur le match en plus de truc c'est que
caruana il est gagnant dans deux parties
il est gagnant dans deux parties et en
plus sur ce match là le truc way
c'est fait caruana contre contre
sarksian là pour la peine le truc non se
passe arts sciences et contre petrossian
le truc c'est que s'il trouve ce dont a
parlé avec maxime
le cavalier prend ici c'est le f 4 à la
fin en fait c'est juste fini la partie
donc c'est à cammas et violents en plus
je trouve que c'est que s'il ya bien un
match où tu peux pas les accusant plus
et sur celui là donc c'est vraiment pas
opportun ce café zoo
c'est sais pas c'est entre guillemets
s'était pas pas de bons matches en fait
ce coffret caruana il rate quand même
max ou cloud dans la dernière il est
vraiment très bien et hyper mais il est
vraiment très très bien et celle contre
sa ration il a vraiment un gain non 26
gagne c'est de partir elle gagne le
match
non plus ce match allait vraiment pas
très suspect maxime qui a eu des matches
beaucoup plus suspect que celui là
m
comme ça il va être nouveau parents il
fait n'importe quoi et qui sont là
depuis quelques parties non c'est même
pas le débreak soit suspect ou pas je
suis d'accord avec toi mais je viens
quand plus au delà de ça
en plus au delà de ça sur ce match là il
ya tellement rien à dire
match est relancé depuis qu'il y avait
plus de suspense en exil américain
vision qu'il a américain sa rivale à
perdre si les trois partis qui fait
n'importe quoi je pensais qu'on avait
gagné ça où il donnait la pièce en un du
coup il allait se remettre et il à
l'enchaînement y joue mal est-ce que je
pense que même vers les favoris des
candidats bah écoute ta ta trois joueurs
quand même qu'ils qui semble un peu se
détache et à hemevée elle tanner peau du
cou qui sont deux qui sont co leaders et
et caruana qui peut peut-être remonter
après on verra comment ça se passe
il faut qu'il la transforme ça tu fais
juste un e 5
je sens que ça doit aller non c'est bien
eux 5
non ils vont envoyer il va peut-être
devoir prendre g4
c'est fini un ce parti-là le pion à eux
est trop fort enfin tous les pions sont
trop forts mais le fou qui va prendre
c'est royal roi qui peut arriver aussi
par là pour gagner les pions il y en a
trop vision qui va sûrement abandonné
ils sont le pion g37 fois f4 du goût il
faut f4 maintenance et enferme la tour
c'est parfait
deux points d'écart vion qui craqua
racines un coup de fatigue
le match peut être vraiment complètement
relancé
le match va être complètement relancé
voir ce qu'il va faire de la green fee
lille a vu maxime dans le chatt biyong
ici l'héroïne grande scène
farouk et j'imagine
on y va rockets il va pouvoir reprendre
des cats avec le pian malhonnête sur une
feuille louey c'est bien de prendre à
deux la demande à maxime ça doit exister
j'imagine ça fait un peu peur
c'est pas une vieille vieille variante
c'est que damas cinq dames 3 2 pages un
vieux truc qui joue peut-être depuis
longtemps
ça fait quand même peur avec les noirs
mais bon si ça tient ça tient dame b
dante 3 pour enfermer la dame madame
eb66 repas ils m'ont soir à ludwig
dams et 4 maintenant pour mettre la
pression sur ce truc là est peut-être
ici aussi peut-être parfois pas froid
certes pas mal aussi ça provoque un peu
les changer tu vas pouvoir faire un e 5
et attaquer là
rhmani qui va faire cinq pour baisser la
pression sur la diagonale et ouvrir son
fou enfin sur des quatre pour être
précis il prend il tolère car l ie 5
décision apparue doit penser qu'il peut
prendre 17 à mesdames pro b 7 est un
truc de marc louis latour v8 on prend
des airs de fou prend ses sept
c'est pour ça qu'il a fait roi g2 pour
pas que ce soit sur échec voilà je vous
annonce que moi je prendrais les noirs
tous les jours mais peut-être un peu de
jeu et ça l'humilie disent qu'ils en
classe à faire l'école à fond où il y
attention hein
ah il se reprend une à 100 reprend un
jong ho c'est terrible au moment où je
disais que le match était fini n'est pas
finie du tout en fait
garçons qui font entre tous les degrés
t arrive c'est terrible pour pour
jefferies qui se prend un nouveau piège
la liasse et b to b 8 fou prend à 7
c'est complètement raide en fait même si
fait d'anne decis damage de damas chain
le roi va partir en e2 ya rien
il joue vraiment pas très bien les 2 1
il ya vraiment une baisse de régime
assez violente
ça me rappelle un peu le manager de
maxime contre oui s'était qualifié va le
speech est junior avec wii qui avait
pris un gros un gros lead face à maxime
et puis et puis quand il a commencé à
s'écrouler en fait maxime il a peut-être
mais on donnait 9 1 ou 10 1 ou quelque
chose comme ça il a complètement écrasé
en fait ça me rappelle un peu ça a des
gars qui joue vraiment très bien un
grillon gay et riga ici deux excellents
joueurs et puis là tu as l'impression
qu'ils sont complètement baissé le
rideau
g négation pour jefferies ouais là là je
penserai que le match dure 4 5 heures
pour être vraiment enfin en sa 404 5
heures ça va pas être assez fort et
faire un match de 8 9 heures pour être
bien sûr là j'ai peur que le format soit
pas suffisant c'est parti si vous
rappelez ans a commencé avec la finale
deux tours qu'il a vraiment mal joué et
je suis pour qui et je sais pas où ils
disent honnêtement je sais pas wiener ça
semble un peu léger répit pu mais ces
formats courts mc speech est sain
ouais la forte impression tous ces tours
il a joué qu'un match en même temps 10 h
on a des sons a démasqué mevel chelsea
grâce à 19,22 démasqué mvs
on pensait que c'était le vrai mais elle
est finalement ta démasqué enfin enfin
démasqué il sévit depuis un moment sur
les tchats sur les stream et finalement
on a réussi à savoir ce n'était pas lui
et pourtant tu avais bien tenu le choc
quoi depuis tout ce temps
bas les masques et la cale vision qu'il
a 20 ans par une belle imposture que ces
nouvelles chaises depuis des années
comment traiter chez bach y avait déjà
pas un tournoi qui pensait pas avoir
joué qu'on savait plus tu avais joué ou
pas à maxime de chez paoute quelqu'un
quitte à laisser jouer en tournant à
hier où j'ai pu tout à dinan jamais joué
ce tournoi après on savait plus
qui est pas eu un truc comme ça on
prépare un tournant ma chance et puis on
en était moi c'est assez égalisant comme
position égalité matérielle c'est bien
et avez raison alors vous c'était aussi
yannick qui avait raison on n'a jamais
su quoi tournoi hier
jamais su et ben ça va être pareil on
n'a jamais sa race et a déjà joué à
bordeaux ou pas mais normalement tu te
rappellerai
je me rappelle quand même dans les
villes dans lesquelles j'ai joué mais
bon après je sais pas
de montsûrs avec ce truc
peut-être les gens ont tellement envie
d'avoir volé contre toi qui se sont
créés des faux souvenirs quoi
bonsoir roupies mentana rome puis moines
à l'as rome qui menace
art et eau ou encore la perdre xiang
mebara l'autre mal autant il fait il
fait n'importe quoi et que donc là je
crois qu'il fait l'abécédaire de ce
qu'il faut pas faire
sinon à tempérer rien on n'est jamais
allé à bord dont 88 c'est réglé ton père
elle a une bonne mémoire le daron est
solide le daron est encore solide
d'ailleurs ici en direct des tournois ou
pas ton daran vous aurez vite fait 800
ils sont fous à moitié
il n'y a pas tout reprend des deux à
tours en d2 il ya tour à 8 je vais faire
le point des deux fous des 4 on y va la
jouer à geaune
mais du coup des fois il est sur la
chaîne pendant les candidats et où le
papa t'inquiète on va pas là on va pas
le troll un peut-être un poil moins
maintenant tu as maintenant que c'est
intéressant qui a les candidats et où il
suit un peu moins d'azur rythme il va
peut-être être champion du monde je dois
arrêter de suivre
bon alors il appert ou pas et xing
jean la chaîne serait marrant en fait il
soit de tenter le tour f4 il a failli
tomber à il va peut-être tomber l'action
du trajet a l'impression que son pion à
y est quand même pas mal là arjun qui
essaye de le faire tomber à tout prix
mais du coup le roi qui s'est un peu
amélioré ses shows de night un les
blancs veulent roye b 4 cavaliers à cinq
endroits b3 qui avale et a33 b3 tour à
6,3 bk 3b cinq cavaliers à 5
ouais c'est fait oya paroisse des saints
qui a laissé cette équipe rang à huit le
marlou et cavaliers b6 tour prend à
cette occasion qui craque complètement
bas et sous 10 et 1 il a tout fait pour
la perdre celle là il s'est mis à mal
autant et il ya eu 8 partout pendant
qu'on discutait avec le chat jay
frictions qui perd toutes ses parties et
ça joue vraiment mal depuis un moment là
8 partout incroyable
et là j'ai envie de dire à woods qui se
lève je sais pas si c'est vraiment
autorisé tout ça je demande en bane du
joueur du joueur indien
pause pipi pour le pipi c'est ce qu'il
dit hein
heureusement qu'ils jouent pas contre
eux wesley so erika ici parfois je leur
match fut serré dans ce format c'est
rarissime à zoug
disons qu'il ya le coup de barre 1 le
coup de barre vraiment mais saluer
sneaker white shaft il reste treize
minutes dans le segment
le coup de barre de fer way tati manque
de fer il fait une anémie un bon et là
il va falloir qu'ils la tienne cela
ouais ouais c'était moi jefferies
bonsoir youpi il menace même pas
vraiment prendre efficace que raffoux
prend à cette dame ces deux prix c3
dams et 2 et on n'a pas caché
7 alors j'ai six têtes retour b1
il se tient peu fait avoir comme date
butoir il ya ici mais qui a l'air
fatigué c'est vrai après il est tard
chez lui il est 23h il est désavantagé
un exemple qui mène à rien on sent la
souffrance sur son visage voilé c'est de
chanter un peu des musiques qui ont pas
l'air d'être très très très bien doit se
remobiliser un il a dû penser que le
match était gagné
je pense qu'il fait un 8 5 min sur les
deux prochaines tu veux dire jefferies à
son cavalier à 5 et pas très bien après
là il va rebondir
peut-être que des si c'était un coup
candidats comme beaucoup précédent pour
empêcher sa déposition de grünfeld une
nouvelle fois
c'est un cas
nv elle n'était pas très en place et il
s'est replacé là il va peut-être y avoir
un dame f4 avec fous j'ai 5 fu g5 food
and arrive cette dame h7
c'est chose faite mais ça il n'a pas vu
que j'ai pris une nouvelle fois c'était
horrible il rate beaucoup de chose est
sûre fois f3 yafo f6 jefferies là ils
regardent plus les coups de l'adversaire
annoncées terribles en fait d'un f4
je crois que sa clôture la partie tu
vois pas tu vois ta phu g5 et g5 f5
encore sa clôture pas mais bon il y aura
des f3 qui vont rodez sa clôture pas
mais il n'a pas du tout vu
e
ouais ouais non c'est c15 il voit plus
les coups adverses
jefferies nous propose tout reprend
fourre tout reprend fou je veux regarder
ce qu'on me propose en ce sens si tu
prends je prends et si tu prends je
prends donc affrété g5 f5 et f3 comme
annoncé ok peut-être il un d'anne decis
encore un truc comme ça ray ils
échangent les dames
mais bon le fou à partir en c2 le foot
va devoir aller en h5 cavalli qui va
arriver à eux six ok il est moins bien
que j'ai pris et tours 6
petit tour des huit qui défendent cavale
il va peut-être doubler et se laisser
changer car les indécis ce tient bien la
baraque 1 cette fois 4 pouces et 6 aussi
peut être une option pour gagner la
colonne eux ça peut être une et mon tour
1 pour commencer j'aime bien je trouve
ça très logique surtout aux six
cavaliers aussi s'y fait h600 premier à
cavaler h3g 5 et le cavalier tient la
baraque croit f2 are what they veut plus
on prend tout reprend des six assez bien
joué ça artistes
alors est ce que c'est si bon est ce que
c'est si bon parce que le pion des 5
il est un peu esseulé il va prendre ces
quatre à y avait trois tours d2 pardon
donc elle va faire à 4 mais il ya ces
quatre ans les rois des cas tout re 5
il fait g4 à la tour c 6 il va prendre
j'ai ici soit c'est chaud les amis il va
encaisser g6 il attaque le foufou jouer
plus vite la côte est côté indien
allez un petit échec qui revient h 4 h 5
attention si férois f7 ouais c'était la
mauvaise
hélas non là il va la perdre
arjun thorpe rangée de roy prend f 4.5
bien joué tour échec tout reprend nantes
on prend il y avait peut-être tour un
échec c'est et du riz laférois prendre
3,5 touriste il va devoir faire échec
pour ses 6,3 points f4 et c'est bien
jouer le petit échec f3 manants qui part
qu' on prend le cas 3 o6 menace matt roi
des six retours ces sept on prend ces
quatre tours f2 tour ses deux bras et ça
c'est nul
et ça c'est nul il va quoi que moi et
non si ça va ça va faire d'am-dam en
même temps prise frisage quatre dames
dame en même temps à iliad ammann huit
dames b8 après on sait show de knight
il y avait d'un v8 dame b 8 à la fin et
il tombe et y tombe
oh mais c'est terrifiant il y avait le
dame d'arrimer le roi et en a quatre ça
faisait d'am-dam damas huit échecs 3b
trois dames v8 3 ces deux ça faisait
d'am-dam mais ça tenait à il a raté le
même truc que moi quand je calculais il
arriverait en fait le roi y en a quatre
as l'impression qui retouche pas la dame
est hilare touche
il y avait juste en prend 1,4
c'est terrible c'est terrible on a raté
le même truc puisque le roi y en a cinq
de base dans la variante et tu le vois
plus ans à 4 quand tu calcules c'est des
fois qu'on les pièces elles ont bougé
dans les variantes oublier tu revois
l'échiquier de base et oublie qu'elle a
bougé la pièce assez terrible away leroy
touché la dahouët leroy touché la dame
c'est dur
alors là c'est une petite française
geffray la questure une série de cinq
défaites ce que rester sauvage accusé
rica ici de triche telle est la question
je crois qu'il est parti régalien c'est
fini là
je remonterai afin de la cadence web en
fait le seul truc s'il y avait un dans
huit échecs roi b3 dalby 8 échecs croit
ces deux et sa protégée une dame qui est
en b1 en fait comme au début de la vente
le roi étant à 5 août avait l'impression
que ça faisait damas à 8,3 b4 dame b 8 3
c3 dame prend bien voir que le roi et en
a quatre c'est terrible - positionné
complètement bordélique mais a quand
même un pion plus pour les noirs tu es
fou des cinq attaquants même rayon de
plus ce que ce que fait j'ai frictions
dans ce moment c'est ce qu'on appelle
choqué
c'est ce qu'on appelle choqué hitchock
ouais qui va lui car il est là il a
voulu jouer j'imagine food et si c'est
venir en f4 mais fo f3 et bien joué et
rigal isi qui semble impose aux femmes
de sa vie
ouais non là il a fait n'importe quoi
avec les noirs car il est ici c'est fou
des 5 c'était space mountain
j'aurais peut-être fait aussi malin mais
on voit tout de suite là que son roi se
retrouve à poil poil poil leroy
génissiat faire roi bessette où la dame
c'est cette île se retrouve en plus dans
le dans un autre viseur non là on voit
que car il est ici sous des cinq ça
allait pas il fallait venir directement
des 5 et peut-être pas faire cavalier g6
allez faut vraiment qu'ils en profitent
la chefferie
bah là il a quand même bien de chacun
allez faut trouver quelque chose pour
ces 1 j'aime bien fait il va réussir à
mettre un quart ayant ces six jours dame
b 6 kgs c6 qui si si ça me donne envie à
puissiez un problème ce que tu as qu'il
prend des buts sur un échec quand même
qui sait si ça donne très envie je pas
si c'est bon
je pense pas que la grippe ou rattraper
donc ouais il a fait fou prend et tour
c6 qui est l'autre option et qui est
peut-être plus fort tu vas faire tout
roger c'est un pas dans le match qui a
complètement qui a complètement échappé
un à jefferies mais bon il avait une
telle avance
voilà on voit que ses katas
on voit que ces quatre rien plus de 4
pour la dame en fait
je rentre en déciderait je crois qu'il
ya encore une partie après celle là dans
cette cadence
ça fait 9 9 c'est ça il va y avoir une
partie encore et c'est serré
et c'est serré il y en eut est enceint
car il y avait 5 0 1
il retourne dans cette grünfeld mais il
joue une autre variante
c'est la dernière partie du segment
il faut en d4
ce cessez de trévisan de gracia quoique
à main comme score
torres qui peut faire [ __ ] en g2
intermédiaire ca ca qui réfléchit fou
prend f8 fou prend h un fou prend 7
reprend 2,4 ce que ce truc sur tout
projet de fou profite souvent atteinte à
peut-être l'impression que damages six
matches mais à quel point est futile a
pas fait je passe c'était bon c'est
intéressant
je pense ça marche et ça paraissait
intéressant projet de voie d'habitude
toujours des comptes avant les bullet
way
à relever est difficile à commentaire on
verra on verra c'est difficile a
commenté ou pas on verra
un bullet y avoir deux importants soient
pas sésame sur ces speech et je suis
déjà à 28 heures de commentaires j'ai
pas j'ai pas encore
j'ai pas encore vivre et une seule
seconde
peut-être là on va pouvoir avoir on va
peut-être voir vibrer 20 30 minutes avec
en 28 heures il s'est passé r ça quand
même un peu long même hélas là ok va se
passer peut-être quelque chose faite moi
je prends les speech est un peu comme un
voyage en train
c'est un peu comme voyager en fait et
speechless entame p6 tour g1 ce
compliqué comme position moi je
prendrais les noirs meybon fo prend 5 ce
que c'est une option ici c'est un coup
tubes à essai 5 et revenir là dessus
alors didonne tourache 8 à main et john
cale ses singles l'air marrant il a fini
par des dons qu'il a fait 5 et cavaliers
affichent 6
tu sors du wagon en marche que tu as
toujours sapé les derniers bullet c'est
faux 19,75 y fait que news c'est une
fête nous j'en ai zappé gens et zapper 2
mais je les ai pas tous zapper dit josh
qui eux qui sévit de fake news dans ce
chat est sûr qu'à rallier prend 1,4 à
qui éprouvent quatre dames 5 et c'est
pour ça que leur didonne cavaliers ont
aimé kg quatre coups de randy c'est dur
ah oui tu empêches échec t'empêche ça et
surtout prend g4 adam problème de dames
g1 et a obstrué
et il a trouvé à une fois que tu l'a vu
avec le redis c'est bien je suis un peu
mis leur dis là du coup avec alger 4
c'est bien vu que maxime les trouver ces
c'est en jouant j'aurais été sûr qu'il
le voit le match et qualitatifs
alors le match est intéressant à suivre
après qualitatif dans le niveau de jeu
je dirais pas je touve à titre perso qui
beaucoup de gaffes paraître g2c le coup
que je pense c'est vrai mais peut-être
qu'on prend à f2
mais ça lucky skin 0,7
sarr est intéressant là ça va être cool
vln tag n'arrive-t-il merci beaucoup kef
pour les décors du jeu d'échecs en
quatre ans vivant j'ai atteint les
niveaux de 1500 sûr tu as comme bravo et
j'en suis très satisfait tu donneras
envie de sa vie de ce jeu c'est génial
encore merci merci à toi tonton brut
belle lots 1500 d'un point f deux tours
cf1 paraître logique haye adam province
est vrai mais d'après cette étude le
fait après puisque pendant tu contrôles
eux trois donc il vient là tu encaisses
g4 et tant qu est ce que tu peux me
prendre de la tour parce que surtout
reprend f1 il ya dame g6 à tour f2 bien
joué roy a eu un tour prend f1 tour f 8
tours f4 c'est ça et sur dame 3 ha oui
tout reprendre ce que ses protégés ouais
c'est hyper chaud les gars alors est ce
qu'on prend un f6 puis on prend un f6
damev 4 h 5 alors à ton espace coiffure
dames e3 maintenant à tous réussissent
dame prend prise prise prise il avait
pas vu sinon il rejouer tempo mais la
tour prend f6 dame pranger cinq tours
projet six prises j'ai six prix g63 f2
roi de 3 alors là les types alors là
peut-être wife trois arrêts mais c'est
lui qui a les coudes attend 3 3 à 6 3 3
à 5 à 3
t'as pas le choix le six pions prend roi
prend au f4 est ce que tu veux cinq rois
des cinq rois f5 b4 bouffe bouffe bouffe
eu sept ans il adam 17 d'am-dam c6 d'un
français au le génie au le marlou au le
marlou
à l'été nul mais il fallait jouer b 3e
set b2 d'am dam à il était même mieux
puisque son pion étaient plus avancées
et c'est lui qui l'a pressé peut-être
dame 17 à huy en plus il fait dame sur
échec pardon oui en plus j'ai même pas
vu adam sur les chalets qui est en train
de calculer date 17 matches 1 mais après
c'est largement assez terrible c'est
terrible d'avoir poussé ses enfants il
avait il avait sept secondes au l'erreur
de débutant en l'erreur de débutant à
les terribles celle-là avec sept
secondes sur la pendule il l'a fait ces
trois or elle est terrible elle est
terrible cette erreur kroi crack rôle
erreur de débutant avec avec du temps
sur la pendule jouer aussi vite une
finale de pions ouais en plus b3 ja b 1
dames sur échec à la fin et non
thierry les joueurs du joueur américain
non il fait il fait beaucoup de gaffes
dans ce match d'ailleurs b prend à trois
et un coup aussi
d'ailleurs quand on y pense même si t'as
pas vu des 3b un échec
admettons dans tous les cas tu fais
passer 3 tu bouffes le pion en fait en
réalité ces trois c'est le coup le plus
con de toute façon tu fais b prend à 3
si jamais tu en fait ces trois c'est le
coût le moins logique détroit parce
qu'en fait si tu fais ces trois sets
c'est de huit prises prise tu dis ok y'a
puis on prend 1,4 fait ça fait aucune
logique ces trois études et tu prends
ici au pire mais prend
faire annuler oui mais je veux dire par
là que c'est plus logique que ces trois
dans tous les cas il n'y a pas de monde
où tu fais c'est 3 normalement il ya des
riches 21,3 plus de ja je fait que
tomber 3 après si tu as des problèmes de
motricité il se moule je sais pas mais
fait quand même attention quoi je
pestais bien chaussé 6e mais en
extérieur ça peut être un peu différent
et tu perds tu t'es rien cassé facile et
que tomber c'est terrible c'est terrible
j'arrive à l'échiquier bibi tombe quoi
c'est génial c'est que ton pays que
c'était cool là c'est le match un peu
serré c'est l'oreille interne ray on
doit mettre trois minutes de plus loin
je vous préviens sa part
en tout cas sympathique cette fin de
du coup les pièces parti à rejouer à
3000 de plus à même avant il y avait
même été six minutes j'ai réussi à
bloquer à 3
j'ai trois épisodes quand je veux pas
être stressé
temps là je vais écrire un petit message
intime et salin que ça reprenne
donc
je vais changer le titre aussi pour
femmes après que fera les parties à
pédagogique
donc
je suis un petit truc en place un
battant je fais la pause ici parce que
je veux avoir le truc dès le début quoi
je veux pas rater
le début
je ne veux pas rater le début
pire les deux côtés je sais pas on lui
demandera mais je pense oui puisque je
refais un retour de 1800 après non après
ces coûts sera fab
mais ça va être dur de faire l'euro tout
2800 cette semaine ce que je suis déjà
claqué et tu vois commenter des matches
comme celui-là ça me fatigue encore plus
donc et camille encore un speech et
juniors et demain et bien évidemment
après demain ce qu'on ait des choses
quand il ya des choses bien
on ne veut surtout pas les arrêter
donc jefferies qui revient
je comprends tu était vénéré hier sur la
fin kim a vénéré
on sera longue à sion veut ne re numéro
62 73 et merci à ft 1700 pour le prime
vénère énervé ouais c'est plus facile
avec les accents m mais j'avais compris
en fait les gars trop laid mais moi
j'étais un peu fatigué à la fin pas je
vais jouer six heures d'affilée quand
même gfi a perdu sur la gelée compris ça
faisait marrer de le troll qu'elle écrit
vénéré et tout le troll d'ailleurs
herbert a perdu en train de voir ça
c'est génial
bondy qui va perdre il va rester gaston
quoi il va être là
mais qu'ils finiraient de fait jour
partir viewer exactement presse et puis
enfin ce truc 2006 ring du coup c'est
dur de réagir au chat
rigaud qui va perdre contre trévise en
incroyable âge aux italiennes
et benoît benoît paire il éliminer non
aussi c'était un père la fina féroé
aussi garcia garcia jean noir elle s'est
qualifiée contre sas nos vaches riga ici
qui obligeait de refilmer son appart
quoi il en doit être en train de se
faire accuser la roya sow qui est en
train d'écrire un mail à règne et rigail
si en sueur il ya ici qui montre son
appart à dire comme fait quand même
gaffe de ne pas trop nous en montrer
gros frissons gossip qui a obligé de
montrer son appart
elle fait quand même gaffe de ne pas
trop nous en montrer ouais j'ai un peu
peur c'est quoi c'est quoi son tee shirt
faut changer de t-shirt jefferies
arrive un must mouchoir usagé ouais mais
sûrement parce que il a un petit rhume
il a un petit rhume jefferies ça arrive
à tout le monde ça arrive à tout le
monde d'avoir leur humain ouais c'est
une nouvelle technique anti-triche ouais
c'est vrai en plus seuls arthur tueur tu
penses trop laid mais en fait c'est
vraiment les nouvelles techniques en
titre y fait suivi juste que le gars
avec qui triche il sort de la pièce
souvent il ya la caméra qui passe et qui
re rentrer si c'était la technique de
jeu lille veulent de la technique
moi j'ai envie de dire attention halak
cachez vous les gars on t'a trouvé la
technique en titre imke ultime quoi aux
tiens je filme à merde c'est vrai qu'une
call 3,60 c'est pas mal comme 3 encore
ça fait très très mal il suffit que tu
es une petite oreille dans l'oreille
c'est a déjà dribbler toute la technique
c'était la caméra qui filme autour ça
sert tellement à rien c'est
extraordinaire c'est
c'est tellement génial en fait enfin
autant tu fais rien quoi autant tu fais
rien va vraiment là c'était c'était la
technique anti-triche l'accusé qu'aux
plus qu'on ait vu dans le monde quoi
alors les amis c'est parti avec ce
bullet jeffrey xiang qui est mené d'un
point il est derrière jeffrey jefferies
qui a complètement craqué mentalement on
pourrait dire que c'est un joueur
français se geffré xiong vu qu'ils
menaient de cinq points qui se fait
écraser donc on va on va être un peu
côté jefferies quand même qui nous
rappelle les bonnes vieilles couleurs
tricolores en face de lui
haroun eric asie joueurs un petit peu
inconnu un des joutes réel mais qui est
bien connu sur internet
il fait partie de ces joueurs indiens
très fort mais qui viennent pas
forcément beaucoup joué dans nos
contrées il est quand même classé au
dessus de 26,30 26,40 excellent blitzer
et jefferies qui directement ce fait des
lions peut doubler sur la colonne sait
mais il a gagné la la paire de fou et il
veut venir avec du cavaliere quatre
cavaliers des cistes entre ami jeffrey
ou peut-être faire du c5 et c4 quai des
six il veut venir taquiner les cases
sakina et de pions bessette haroun qui
qui mais qui fait le grand roi qui
défend le pion bessette et là on l'a vu
un petit peu faire un petit mouvement de
tête
jefferies jefferies en sueur après le
grand roque du coup il part pour qui et
b3 qui essaient 5
il va se faire échanger les fous de
cases blanches il va perdre le lion
pensée 3 jefferies qui repart aussi mal
qu'il avait terminé le 3 + 1 en sueur il
va déjà il ya les pions qui tombe mais
va se venger sur bessette il aura qu'un
pion de - jefferies il peut même prendre
tête du cavalier rebondir vers des six
finalement est une menace est décalé
lieu 4 avait quitté qui est des six
alors là il va faire qu'il est prend 17
ça paraît évident et il va rebondir en
d6 peut avoir des rebonds aussi en f7
avoir yaya toure qui va arriver en
bessette c'est pas si clair il a quoi il
a sept secondes d'avancé note jeffrey
note chez free mais il a deux pions de
moins alors le cavalier qui parents des
six est ce qu'une tour peut arriver en b
c'est tout ça sert à rien dans le roi va
venir eux aussi s'il va être impérial
car il y avait cet hymne à ski et ses
cinq coups de marloux côté américain et
peut-être une tour qui va partir alors
elle part où elle par an
et quatre pour bloquer la colonne des
apparences et kara tenons ces droits qui
part en 8 3 17 qui a et b 7 ça répète si
c'est pas possible il accueille ses cinq
quand même
il va falloir se décider la tour qui
part en ckd j'imagine tour d un tour des
six leroy qui va partir en effet été une
tour qui va peut-être venir vers 17 avec
l'idée de faire des cahiers des six
échecs ça peut être une possibilité il
prend aux sept cavaliers prendre 7 et
tour prend assise d'accord il récupère
un pion avec les blancs mais il a
toujours un pion de moins et les noirs
sont complètement réorganisé le cavalier
bessette qui est mal placé la tour qui
va arriver en c2 et maintenant peut-être
un cavalier qui peut jaillir vers des
4es venir embêter sur tours d un roi
bouge qu'il prend des quatre prises des
4 tours des 4% ya peut-être un tour d un
qui peut venir sauver est ce que c'est
ce qu'on va voir oui ils du coup il fait
pour ces quatre y défend cavaliers prend
des cats il veut peut-être prendre de la
tour puis prendre du pillon et monte son
roi alors est ce que le roi va être
assez fort pour accompagner le pion dès
que la finale soit gagnante j'imagine
que théoriquement non mais il reste peu
de temps sur la pendule pour les deux
joueurs et ça peut être compliqué il
peut aussi aussi trouver du tour du
contre jeu via tour à sept tours angers
ça va être très tendu l'échangé tour est
proposée aux droits des trois on n'a pas
le temps d'encaisser le pion donc il est
refusé cet échange
mais là tout revient à harceler le roi
le roi qui vient avec catherine tour 17
maintenant peut-être à il fait tour d2
il s'en prend aux pions af23 f3 le
retour il va peut-être commencer à
envoyer g5 avec qui des deux fers tour
ces trois de chasser le roi ou d'envoyer
les pions comme il le fait mais la torah
5 est bien placée elle va se venger sur
le pion g5 c'est chose faite et il
attaque le pion j'y vais avoir tout
reprend g3 maintenant échange des tours
wade 3,3 gk3 des cas 3g 3 et ça se
termine sur une nulle plutôt bien payé
pour le joueur américain
allez on est de retour c'est maintenant
le joueur indien qui a les pièces les
pièces blanches alors il refait un
petite fille en quête au ca va retourner
non pas du tout ça retourne plus du tout
dans l'est
dans les greens failed ça rentre dans un
truc qui joue souvent en bullet sont des
petits fiant kétou des petits g3 et ça
va la jouer en douceur tout doucement à
l'esa vient échanger en d4 des chevaux
non elle est peut-être un petit dams et
huit fois je crois à la wla d'un effet
qui a valu 8 pour qualifier cette
peut-être essayer d'un petit peu et
changer tout ça peut-être qu'il prend
des quatre qui va arriver aussi
ils seront mangés un cavalier en bessin
qui va mettre la dame ans et 8 il
prépare peut-être un flash 3 alors est
ce qui va tolérer x 6 oui mais bon il
fait froid je crois en premier x 6 on va
échanger un peu tout ça j'imagine que tu
vas faire un fou pranger deux noms et
commence par cas va lieux saints qui les
change ici que sur coup franc j'ai trois
mois je crois d'un point je crois y aura
cavaliers g4 donc ça ait changé il ya
toujours cette belle classe b 5 pour le
cavalier mais c'est pas assez pour pour
prétendre un avantage décisif côté blanc
le cavalier qui se dirige vers ses 5 et
peut-être même à 6 b46 il en al'envie à
la case 6 aussi adam 4 aussi qui peut
qui peut se jouer à tout moment le cac
volley qui se redirige vers des cinq on
est maintenant dans une structure de
pions de type ma roxy sauf que le pion
est resté sur la case de donc les blancs
vouloir faire un tour d un tour des deux
tours d un c'est de bouger ce cavalier
en bessin qu'attaquer le pion le pion
des six le pion des six qui disparaît en
venant à eux cinq sont rechange de
structures de pions et maintenant on a l
femmes aux options isolé qui va falloir
bloqué puis attaqué il ya aussi
peut-être ces cases noires autour du roi
qui peut être intéressant de chercher à
toucher alors là juste pour dire
l'ordinateur creek il faut jouer f6 d'un
bouger des cats qui gagne une pièce mais
f6 dame pro f 6
il faut voir tout reif 8 mois donc et
c'est
et tous rêvent sans qu'ils aient des
quatre il va pas le voir trop compliqué
c'est juste un jeu
il le voit au haut et au très très bien
joué de la part de jefferies damev six
tours f8 la dame doit rester au contact
du cavalier elle doit repartir en 5
tours f5 dames 3 des 4 alors là je dis
chapeau monsieur là je dis chapeau bas
monsieur jeffrey là je dis chapeau bas
chapeau bas monsieur le chapeau et
baisser parce que f 6 e tour f 8 tours
f5 des 4 honnêtement il faut y penser il
faut y penser
d'ailleurs dame cinq tours f5 dames 3
des 4 il va y avoir encore d'amd de hay
fait dame b 8 échecs bon mais ça ça a
gagné une pièce mais là c'est très très
bien joué très très très bien joué de la
part de la part de jefferies qui a sorti
le kia senti le truc il a réfléchi au
bon moment en fait il a pris il a pris
le temps il a pris eux
il a pris 20 secondes pour jouer le coup
dans un bullet c'est énorme de prendre
20 secondes pour un coût il a senti la
tension qui les prend il peut y avoir
des dames c4 et c'est bien joué dans me2
il attaque il attaque il va faire créer
des tueries d'un problème de la du coup
il défend même pas le pion il veut pas
prendre des quatre dames et froid
cavaliers g5 peut-être ou cavaliers à
cavalier g5 direct ouais parce que sur
dame pranger 5 adam prend des seins et
là ils menacent cavaliers h3 mat
donc il va y avoir un échec une dame qui
vient f1 cavaliers h3 quand même dame
prend h3 dame prend d un exceptionnel de
la part de jefferies qui a trouvé le f 6
qui étaient vraiment difficiles en
bullet ah ouais vraiment difficile je
sais pas ce que je vois à maxime dans le
chat chez pas ce qui ce qu'ils en
pensent mais j'ai assez impressionné
qu'il est qu'il ait vu cette combinaison
est donc ça fait 10 partout entre les
deux hommes
et je vais essayer de de rajouter de
rajouter un chrono là parce que ça et
qu'on n'a pas le chrono il nous faut un
chrono les gars je vais je vais je vais
je vais le chercher de ce pas attendez
il me faut il me faut une petite seconde
là
il faut que je récupère à que je
récupère alors leurs chronos officiels
pour que je sache combien il reste deux
temps thomas je fais la petite manip et
et on y retourne tout de suite ça permet
de faire une petite respiration parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a vu beaucoup de
choses là depuis depuis dix minutes
le chrono officiel qui reste forte et
une minute trente à peu près on va aller
se chercher ça et on va voir ce qui se
passe dans cette partie chrono qui par
nom jeffrey avec l'evian et c'était un
petit une petite slave ça j'ai pu le
voir les noirs qui ont réussi à réaliser
la percée c5 généralement c'est bien et
on se retrouve maintenant avec le pion
isolé en d4 est une organisation le fou
qui n'est pas à sa place
le foot doit être ici souvent à deux
soit en b enfin il doit être sur une de
ces quatre cases en fait et en e2 il est
pas au bon endroit alors à savoir s'il a
le temps de le recycler mais du coup il
a une pièce mal placé et ça peut vouloir
dire que les noirs sont bien il peut
faire des fous g5
ils échangent tout efois 5 alors
ça c'est pas conventionnel comme plan
mais ça fait très mal parce qu'ils
forcent il force f5 et c'est pas c'est
pas terrible sarouel à sa rente de
partout la jefferies qui fait mal hein
dame b5 et menace d'armes 8
là ils menacent partout il menace
d'armes français 8 il a fait très mal
hein jeffrey je peux vous dire qu'ils
trouvent des dés qu'il ya des qui
alourdit qui s'emballe sur un coup et
qu'il ya une combinaison tactique j'ai
pris la trouve fouet cette dame f7 est
fou prend aussi soin il a réussi à
combiner aller il un pion de plus dans
cette finale elle n'est pas encore
terminée il faut faire attention on peut
encore se prendre un genre de baies 3 x
3 et b2b 1
c'est bien joué b3 pour cette raison là
ça bloque bien ça empêche cette idée de
deux pions passé et maintenant il va il
va gagner le pion à il va revenir en c6
et il va les envoyer à 5 à 6 à 7
le fou en c4 qui est maître est roi et
feu rouge et un pour faire rejouer le
futur cases noires ça devrait gagner
tranquillement pour jefferies qui va
reprendre le lead
il va reprendre le lit de notre petit
jefferies et puis qui par an à 6
peut-être la seule chance est de prendre
à 6 et prendre des cinq mêmes ça ce
n'est pas grand chose là le pion qui
file en ascète ya trop de matériel en
plus il n'ya pas de monde où ça gagne
pas il va devoir échanger
alors il va réussir à récupérer le pion
à mais pendant ce temps là le roi va
aller s'occuper des trois pions la hache
6 g 5 f 4 qui vont tomber les uns après
les autres et maintenant ch qui part ça
fait un point d'avancé à présent pour
pour jefferies qui reprend le lead après
un gros passage à vide un long passage à
vide ils se réveillent tactiquement il
fait mal alors avoir un genre de moderne
thierry pire qu il se prépare pour les
parties pédagogique de vlad et il envoie
donc le double fiant kétou et le d6 c5
on voit les deux fous qui brille bien
mais la position est très complexe il ya
beaucoup de choses possibles donc des
princes est qui et qui est une
possibilité d'apprendre à me prendre 3
prend tout re 1 et peut-être un cavalier
e 4 qui va faire mal à la fin ouais tour
en échec c'est sur le roi
si par sur a86 à me bloque une tour et
là il ya cavaliers des six qui menace
est bien fou prend 2,4 et fous des deux
fois à 5 tours d1
voilà ça va faire mal là on attaque le
fou alors est-ce qu'on fait food et 5
mai on n'attaque pas vraiment le pion
cependant est ce qu'il ya une autre case
il fait froid à cinq échecs au 1er tour
des seins alors sur quel point 4 il veut
tout reprend 1,4 et il espère avoir
cavaliers prend des 4 après alors là il
peut pas le faire parce que ses protégés
par deux pièces mineurs et sur g4 il
veut cavaliers des six et il défend tout
donc les blancs qui jouent ces trois
c'est logique tours 8
il se développe il propose les changes
détour sa échanges et il va pouvoir
gagner le pion des quatre mais il va y
avoir tour 4 qui va arriver
donc il fait roi f2 alors maintenant il
fait cavalier 3 avec les noirs ils
attaquent la tour la tour qui doit
partir en d2 ou en d3 et le cavalier qui
va repartir vers ces quatre et qui va
attaquer le fou qui va devoir partir à
verre asahi non il le fait pas il prend
des trois ils menacent une découverte et
qui prend b2 contre attaque là tout
retour des 2 kgs c4 le retour tour d un
il va prendre à 5 maintenant les blancs
ou faire qui a et b trois rois c'est
cette cave alias 5
non il va partir en recettes et comme
anne on est en fait il doit trouver une
bonne case
il va peut-être partir je sais pas où il
va partir en fait il doit faire [ __ ]
en c3 après ouais donc il fait pas et
par an c'est cette île fait pas fou
prend ses 3 il fait tour 4 qui est très
bien joué les amis il veut jouer tour à
4 et prendra deux mois il est il en
train de donner une leçon là jeffrey
gong à son adversaire là il est
impressionnant le joueur américain
il a vraiment élevé le débat là tout
d'un coup bas il va prendre ses trois de
pions passé lié en plus est sur un coup
de tours pour clouer iab et quatre mois
il est vraiment il est vraiment impérial
fou des quatre ans à 3 puis on prend à
deux en dame ça va faire ça à faire deux
points de plus pour jefferies orange et
free qui acquit appuyé sur
l'accélérateur là il est il est vraiment
au dessus moi il est vraiment au dessus
de son adversaire à présent on a
vraiment l'impression qui a qu'un joueur
sur l'échiquier il voit toutes les
tactiques il faut absolument tout il a
fallu il a fallu attendre ce moment pour
retrouver le jefferies qu'on connaît et
là il va avoir une structure
ouais non il n'a pas structures
inférieures il vous prend ses 3 il va
avoir la même structure que tout à
l'heure savent que les les noirs aussi
ont des pions doublé il va pouvoir jouer
peut-être perdu ses cinq tours b un
fouet f3 et attaquer le pion bessette
c'est un petit avantage blanc il a fait
tourner un pour interdire le grand roque
qui n'avaient pas pu dans la partie
avant qu'en savez protéger bessette et
là il va avoir un petit avantage avec
les blancs il va faire ses seins qui va
échanger père de fou est il un pion
passé alors que les noirs ont les pions
doublé sur leur majorité
et là attention pour pour erika ici
parce que à la tour c 'est tiassou
décisif où bessette et ça va encore
gagner là pour jefferies jefferies en
démonstration la en bullet wef ou des
six tours bouge fou besset tour des huit
pouces et si ça va tout prendre en d6
seuil à tomber 8 maths à la fin s'est
terminée après france et 6 il n'a pas vu
le match du couloir le joueur indien
wallace et démonstrations de jefferies
impressionnant impressionnant de
maîtrise orale et les points les points
s'enchaînent là il faut l'arrêter
arrêtez les amis arrêtez le voilà c'est
la honte tada c'est c'la massacra d'à
côté côté côté indien il se prend une
ruine maintenant ouais là il va falloir
arrêter jefferies il en fait trop
il en fait trop il boxe eu quatre
catégories au dessus de derrida ici dans
cette cadence après après quel est
l'impact aussi de l'horaire du match
quand même il faut souligner que
jefferies doit jouer ce match entre
entre 11h30 et je sais pas exactement
son fuseau horaire mais il y joue à
alléger passé entre 11h30 et 17h le
delta de son jeu sans savoir exactement
alors que côté indien il est déjà minuit
vous de nuit et on connaît l'impact
l'impact de la condition et de la
concentration dans ces joutes et c'est
vrai que quand on a à jouer quatre
heures d'affilée devoir jouer le soir et
la nuit c'est un des avantages réels
est ce que c'est ce que payent
actuellement à rooney et giggs ou est-ce
que simplement intrinsèquement il était
en sur régime et il commence à le payer
en tout cas la tour va arriver en c4
latour ans et 8
regardez les fous noir qui sont braqués
sur le centre le cavalier âge de mal
placé les pièces blanches n'ont aucune
harmonie ça risque de faire plus 4 pour
jefferies qui ne s'arrête plus les amis
et il est concentré comme geagea il est
à fond là ça doit à la caméra il est
beaucoup plus impliqué que tout à
l'heure
hélas là on voit là la pression pression
de dingue qui est mise à et parce fouet
par ce fourbe et 7 / j2ee par le fou g7
sur des quatre les deux fous qui font
mal jefferies est peut-être un cavalier
des cinq ans qui peut arriver et changer
mettre le fou en dessin qui va qui va
matraquer b3 jefferies qui recommencent
à danser ses mauvais signal à pour pour
le joueur indien
les partis qui filent et qui se
ressemblent pareil on le sent désemparé
à l'écran il va perdre hyper l' hyper
hyper des quatre il ya tout qui tombent
les amis alors à la tour qui arrive en
des huit en plus qui attaquent le fou
cavaliers qui prend b3 ça tombait la
tour qui arrive en c3 il se reprend un
clouage caillé qui revient en d4
il va peut-être à surprise est royal où
pranger six tours prend des huit brèves
écart alliage 5 empêche les chèques
c'est très bien joué on y voit trou il
voit tout un an jefferies et il va
envoyer le pion à yvan qui va partir
colonna et regarder la case a un qui est
contrôlé par le fou ça va être ça va
être compliqué alors là peut-être pour
le mans / à saint-cast foot pro f 5
tours prend d un fou pranger si c'est
tout reprend d1
c'est pour ça qu'ils marquent un temps
d'arrêt de joueurs américains alors
peut-être un coup comme fouet f6 du cou
pour protéger non ils échangent en g3 il
faille par avec tourbe et 8/10 fils le
pion il va récupérer f3a et tour f1 bien
joué qui va sceller le
le sort de la partie et arjun qui
réussit à arrêter l'hémorragie et donc à
rester à garder quelques chances dans ce
match il reste quoi il reste 10 minutes
30 10 minutes 30 ça fait une deux trois
quatre peut-être même cinq parties à
l'ets peut encore y avoir cinq parties
après celle là à voir si jeffrey la joue
pendant cinq ans de quoi laïcards où il
peut la jouer pendant très longtemps sa
lascives
il peut jouer 49 coup il peut jouer 49
ou pas plus sain et il va le faire
il va le faire alors c'est pas très
classe mais il à l'ide il allie donc il
peut le faire après
c'est à erika ici d'être devants dans le
match s'il voulait pas qu'on qu'on lui
fasse une tour nico tentes aux
incroyables rigail zee qui donne la
partie et qui donne le match
ah ouais non là c'est eux voilà là là
c'est un peu un peu match dos ouais
c'est dommage là de se pendre le roi
prend des cinq qui va sceller le le
destin de ce match
finalement on a vu un il était un peu
désabusé arjun un peu désabusé il était
derrière un dans le bullet hell a non
seulement il a perdu mal de temps mais
en plus il a perdu le point 14 14 points
10 minutes 30 en dix ans cette partie 3
6 9
allez il peut y avoir quatre cinq
parties max cinq parties max c'est à
dire que s'il perd la moindre partie
c'est fini il doit tout gagner à présent
le joueur indien et ça va être compliqué
parce qu'on voit que jeffrey de toute
façon va jouer les parties à fond je
pense qu'il reste même que quatre
parties honnêtement et ce qui inquiète
français 5 qui marche
est-ce que kay prend ses cinq marches il
ya tout reprend ses cadres d'après leur
dis ouais tout bêtement mais là
jefferies qui est en train de mettre la
sphère dans le sac
tu es français s'inquiète on prend ces
4es qui fait très très mal et tout
reprend ses 2 et là le cavalier a pas
qui a et des six à cause de cas et des
cinq tours prend b2 vrai et jefferies
qui a une poubelle mais oui la dernière
partie c'est dommage a en fait arjun qui
attendait là nul et qui a oublié que son
adversaire pouvait bouger le roi et il a
oublié qu'il fallait pas faire de
multiples et move alors il fait qu'il y
ait des cinq maintenant
du coup ils menacent la dame ya le
cavalier en l'air derrière ces dames
français de il attaque la tour ils
attaquent f2 alors jefferies va essayer
de la défense le plus longtemps possible
là on a compris que qui voulait mettre
toutes les chances de son côté
donc il va il va défendre le maximum de
coups et déjà vais essayer de pas la
perdre mais il va de toute façon tenté
de se faire mater le plus loin possible
via les plus une seconde qu'ils peuvent
faire jouer pendant longtemps mais la
position il passe six fins et les vieux
mieux pour les noirs évidemment mais
elle est pas si simple simple ou la f4
ces risques et ça c'est hyper risquaient
de souffrir le roi mais il pense que la
dame en a huit tient tous donc ça va
échanger il va vouloir gagner avec le
pion à attention tout de même rush de et
plus ou moins forcé dam des quatre leur
tour dames f3 il va vouloir a4 a3
j'imagine alors il va partir pour des
échecs
il laisse le pion f4 d'accord allez
bouge leroy hill rebouge leroy 3 et 4 il
va ramener la dame en a huit ça c'est
logique on sait bien jouer ça à la
montée du roi wahou
belle idée et d'am dam c5 et cavalier e
4 ah ouais c'est super bowl à ce qu'il
vient de faire
alors attention y'a pas de maths à
l'étouffée il n'y a pas de
tu à l'étouffée voyez cavaliers mais ça
va quand même gagner s'il le fait arrive
à échanger par le problème c'est que
j'ai free va pouvoir jouer vite beaucoup
de coups à la déjà les repères la pièce
mais ça reste complètement gagnant
puisque le pion est quasiment de la
valeur du cavalier en réalité parce que
lecavalier bloqué à empêcher la
promotion du pion et donc ça se gagne
normalement en envoyant des pions passé
mais il faut faire gaffe de ne pas se
prendre un échec quelque part l'ajfer
qui est des six vraiment là il fait
n'importe quoi
il a ce faire la dame est la position
est complètement perdue il aurait pu
gagner plus de temps en temporisant plus
longtemps il va refaire un échec ici
comment les va jouer le maximum de coups
une nouvelle fois et là il va attendre
jusque yamato prochain il va attendre il
va laisser filer énormément de temps
jefferies il reste plus que six minutes
il ya trois points d'écart mais il va il
va les avoir un ces trois parties il va
avoir ses trois parties donc il peut
encore il peut il peut encore gagner le
il peut encore revenir faire match nul
et gagné le match aller donc du coup
maintenant on a une nouvelle une
nouvelle moderne avec une structure qui
va être en étonnement roxy quand le bus
arrive en c4 avec défiance les taux des
deux côtés la position est complexe ça
va jouer il va se manger car mal petit
chez free on va avoir un vrai c'est bête
qu'il ait perdu la partie des fous de
couleurs opposées montgré ouais parce
qu'il y aurait deux points d'écart mais
c'est vrai que c'est bon c'est un peu ça
qui est énervant parfois dans le jeu en
ligne mais après ça lui à lui de faire
attention donc il met une petite
pression il ya voir les récupère un
centre il va pouvoir faire 5
il fait briller son fou j'ai deux ans
avec avec les blancs et ils enferment le
fou g7 et il enferme le cavalier aussi
il ya des g4 qui rôde il est très bien
notre ami
notre amie erica ici il est très bien
alors est ce que tous ces deux et un
coup il ya juste g4 son tour ces deux
voilà elle est allée dur à jouer pour
pour jefferies il est plus ou moins
obligé de faire un truc comme ça il va
se prendre un damache quatre cavaliers
g5 et riga ici qui joue très vite
alors il a le temps un faux pas qui se
pressent trop je veux dire par là qu'il
faut pas qu'ils se mettent la pression
avec le chrono la fin du match et c'est
parce qu'il a il a le temps d'en avoir
trois parties et il peut faire un
retournement de situation il faut juste
qu'ils qui joue qui joue à sa main et
qu'ils l'emportent ce que l'on y met la
pression il se fait échanger lecavalier
qui va revenir au cices il a raté il a
raté quelque chose à ce cavalier va être
super fort tour ces deux et maintenant
c'est le roi blanc qui est un peu mal la
dame qui va venir au 1,8 et ce que voit
il n'y a pas de rebond de dames pour le
moment mais il va partir avec damas
quatre away non là il se fait
complètement contre a- adam g 4 qui
arrive et on il nous manque un coup pour
pour mater et là elle à la maintenance
et les noirs qui attaque
bon allez il est mieux autant notre ami
notre ami haroun il faut en profiter un
là ils envoient aussi c'est bien joué il
s'ouvre la case des cats pour aller
mater peut-être un jour enfin deux
variantes et là il ya un dame ses trois
échecs pas piquée des hannetons qui ont
projeté ici ces dames prend b2 à les
salles lé gagnant ne faut pas la rater
côté côté indien il va prendre une
rafale d'échec quand même qui va être
désagréable mais il se met sur cases
noires il va faire d'alger trois fiefs
de ça il apparaît tous les échecs et
maintenant il va falloir faire le taf
assez bien joué ça et touré fuite dame
prend un f3 way ou comme ça voilà ils
échangent des dames jefferies qui va pas
être classe ça on l'a compris va aller
jusqu'au matin à chaque fois faut pas
faire de pâtre faut prendre son temps
côté
côté indien alors ne pas prendre trop
son temps non plus c'est quand même
dommage de mettre autant de coups à
mater mais allez c'est bien ça fait le
taf mais c'est pas sûr qu'il y arrive
c'est pas sûr qu'il y arrive
il reste 3 10 et 3 10 et short pour pour
gagner une partie
il faut que je regarde j'ai pas le
chrono officiel après il reste être un
petit peu plus à l'est il faut il faut
qu'il fasse le taf a review nez c'est
tellement dommage qu'il ait perdu cette
partie à [ __ ] couleur opposée tout à
l'heure pour ça on nous vante un
toujours les bienfaits de ce format qui
jouent sur des heures moi j'y vois
surtout beaucoup de beaucoup de défauts
mais bon peu importe allez on va on va
espérer une remonte à la de folie du
joueur indien
allez faut tout donner dans cette partie
après il est obligé de jouer vite en eux
arjun mais c'est bien il va mettre la
pression autant à son adversaire
ils jouent tous tempo là quand même il
ya une menace de dessins qui à la tour
qui est cloué ça fait quand même ça fait
quand même assez mal hélas il n'a pas de
choix là il peut pas avancer masqué il
doit gagner cette partie là sur des cinq
du coup il peut prendre prendre et
reprendre de la dame
attention tout de même à ce clou agen
les pièces noires qui sont complètement
recroquevillé ça fait peur
pour ces huit fois ci s'il va repartir
avec tours b 8 du coup il va se
faciliter la vie
alors jefferies qui tente de trouver de
trouver une solution pour percer le
verrou indien a annoncé s'est trouvé
cinq fait gaffe tu peux pas faire nul
gros il peut pas il a pas il n'a pas le
roy ladurie n'y a pas qu'elle prend 1,5
à dame france et cette île fait m6
alors est-ce qu'il va pouvoir sortir le
fou verger 6
il fait d'amd 6 pour le moment à et
maintenant il ya des cinq a plus d'amour
en dessin qui a poussé quatre os il
s'est pris la petite combine est et
dames france s est alors là c'est
terminé les amis ouais si jeffrey ne
perd pas avec qualité deux pions plus le
match le match sera gagné côté côté
américain
il méritait quand même il a été un peu
plus fort l'accueil des quatre cas ici
six des sept des huit ça rentre tout
seul ça rentre tout seul car lycées 6 ya
pas tout prendre et si sa cavale ie7 on
prend des six
attention le match du couloir mais ça il
va le voir tous les coups gagnants fait
tomber 8 échange les tours et il va
mettre le carillon b8 par la suite il
fait tout recettes ça gagne aussi tous
gagnants et 17 peu abandonné 1 à 2
joueurs amiens mais il a l'air d'être
écoeuré a de façon il sait que si
personal match est terminé il va aller
jusqu'au bout mais c'est là que ça va
s'arrêter un match qui aurait été serrée
jusqu'au bout et qui se sera perdue sur
des détails un côté indien alors par une
déconnexion ou quelque chose du genre
là il ya plus de ya plus d'échappatoire
et c'est terminé
victoire de jeffrey xiong
donc il se qualifie pour les
demi-finales pas censé être faire sans
s'être fait peur parce qu'il ya vraiment
une
un moment du match où il n'a pas été
très très bon ils menaient de cinq
points
il s'est retrouvé derrière d'un point
après avoir avant après avoir autant
mener finalement sur les bulles est un
jeune qui a eu à un moment d'absence et
qui a perdu quatre parties
consécutivement et c'est finalement là
qu'il a perdu le match
ouais c'est terminé
alors au bout de sa vie est mesquine
c'est fait c'est gagner un côté côtes
américains donc je vais mettre une
petite pub ici
après on va on va se retrouver enfin
vous allez vous retrouver avec fap moi
je serai juste là pour faire la mise en
place et les premières secondes et après
je vous laisserai avec fab pour pour les
petites partie pédagogique sur sur la
pire qu pas là on va faire le changement
maintenant de façon le match est terminé
c'est gagner on se retrouve dans
quelques secondes je vais envoyer le
raid